are you aware of what it's like to talk
to you
um no
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like my days
this is probably all right before i
introduce
our guest i'm going to butter them up a
little bit i'm going to butter them up
because
i'm i'm genuinely excited for this i
there's probably like three or four
podcasts so far that i'm like oh yeah
this is one that
i wake up in the morning i'm excited to
do i know that if we do a good job this
is going to be one people's favorite
podcast
why is that well this is the best it's
not morning
it's going to be midnight soon where
brayu is yeah we got up late or we
stayed up late yeah but that's all right
it's my birthday by the way today so
this is how
my wife was like what do you want to do
for your birthday i was like don't worry
it's already planned i'm doing a podcast
i love it
um so anyways the the reason i think
this project
podcast can be good this episode is
going to be good is because our podcast
is all about ideas people
listen to this pod they wake up and they
listen to this pod because we get the
wheels turning we present new and
interesting ideas or we talk about
spaces
or we talk about spaces in ways that you
haven't heard too much before
now one of those one of the ways that i
get a bunch of my ideas is from our
guest biology
who is who is here and he has been i
don't know what the exact quote was but
i think mark andreasen at one point
called you
like the highest ideas per minute of
anybody he's met is there
do you know that quote that i'm talking
about he he sort of yeah
kind remark uh i he said they were
useful ideas too which is good so
um uh for our ideas people don't usually
call them useful but that's okay
entertaining is okay yes we teach people
how to like
launch like a porn app you teach people
you warn the world of a pandemic uh so
like
your your podcast is actually very
popular and i've heard a lot of people
say good things about it so
don't be too hard on yourself it's good
thank you thank you um
and i think that you know one of the
like if the
a lot of people ask us like oh you know
who do you guys follow who do you guys
read
you're one of my answers to if i started
a new twitter account and i had to
follow five people
to like get that information flowing in
who are the five kind of must follows
i think you would definitely be in there
for me and sam i know you've been
following as well so
we'll give kind of like a very quick
rundown but then we have a bunch of
topics that i think are exciting we're
going to talk
about a bunch of crypto things because i
think you're uh very forward thinking in
the crypto world we're going to talk
about some non-crypto things
um as well and then we'll all try to uh
steer clear of too much controversy and
you know let's let's play ball nobody
get cancelled here we go so
um so biology is here at one point you
were you're a founder of i believe
um a genetics company or a biogenetic
company
how would you describe your first
company what was the kind of category
you would call that one um
clinical genomics so basically
um you know one of the first companies
to use genomics in
medicine uh and basically we took
if you've heard of tay sachs or sickle
cell these sort of genetic diseases
mendelian diseases that you probably
learned about in high school
those are simple genetic diseases where
they can be predicted by
usually just variation in one gene and
um we did is we took all of those at the
same time
and test them at once with a universal
genetic test and that was one of the
first
applications of genomics in the clinic
where the scalability of it the fact
that you could assess many different
markers many different
variants at the same time allowed you to
cut costs relative to your traditional
one one gene or one variant at a time
blood test
which i actually uh just used i used it
my wife and i uh for
freezing embryos um used you it's what's
it called miriam
yes women's health um you know division
but basically it was it was called clu
and syl council
as an independent company um so like i i
saw the packaging in the
trash can and i was like oh wait i know
this name
and so yeah so sean that's what we used
it for the classic
cloud that could be of assistance um i
think it's interesting because uh
that's a space which has sort of just
evolved in its own way
um you know genomics and biomedicine it
hasn't really
linked up with the main body of tech um
you know of like internet technology
consumer technology it might do so this
decade we'll see
um hasn't yet it's sort of like how you
know
like high frequency trading and all the
type of stuff is its own kind of sub
area
and crypto has now linked it up with the
main body of tech
you know where it's programming uh you
know programming on top of
blockchains right um now that we have
under 30 million
sequence genomes and lots of people with
genotypes i forget the latest number but
both 23andme ancestry.com there's
millions of people who have personal
genomes uh albeit genotypes rather than
full sequences
i think we're going to start to see more
kind of you know computations a lot of
genomes have been installed
in the same sense like a personal
computer's install it's a piece of
software
right or data rather locally on your
computer that you can do things with
that's a whole separate topic
happy to dive into that if you're
interested and what and what did you do
after that
um so i was and that was like a sorry
actually that was like a 300 million
dollar exit or something yeah
yeah well like like pretty wildly
successful it was good it was good yeah
it was a good company and um i think
you know so after that there's a bunch
of things um i was an early investor
in cryptocurrencies so bitcoin ethereum
um zcash a bunch of other ones you've
heard of
i shouldn't say every major coin but
every major coin that i think has some
technological innovation
you know i've probably got like
something in it not every single one but
a lot of them
um early investor in superhuman
soylent cameo lambda school replit
uh mighty a bunch of others have all
done fairly well
um you know a deal if you just saw this
became a unicorn or whatever last week
all things that sort of i think fit my
philosophy um because
you know i sort of invest in invest in
things that
help to improve quality of life in the
future that i envision
and so you know uh
some somebody mike with um crypto for
example
crypto is built for the apocalypse but
with internet
right you know soylent you know that
type of stuff right and you know
there's an apocalypse and there's a
rebirth after that and so i kind of
think
of that is sort of this stack of
technologies you can kind of view it
from that lens of
the unbundling and fracturing of all
20th century all pre-internet
institutions and then the
rebundling of them back together into
new
internet native forms i think very few
institutions that
predated the internet will survive the
internet in the fullness of time
so i want to ask you oh sorry go ahead i
think i think
sean that um before we like really get
into it though i did want to call out i
think
uh we want to call his latest project
right because i want
we might talk for a little bit i want to
i want to be able to promote that
right away as opposed to in the end so
you want to well sean you want to take
it from there
yeah well i'll let you introduce it but
uh super interesting project
i believe the url is 1729.com so just
the numbers
17 1729.com and it's
really simple and i love simple simple
idea which is
it's a newsletter that pays you so it's
a newsletter that you get that has these
little micro tests so i got one
i don't know it was yesterday the day
before it was basically like you can get
3 000 bucks in bitcoin
if you create memes that will promote
you know crypto and india or you know
help
help package that idea in a way that's
shareable and spreadable that's what
memes are
um around crypto and india and so there
are these little tasks that come out
and so it's a newsletter that you read
not just for like sam's got a newsletter
2 million subscribers the hustle they
give information
but it's sort of like a pat it's like
you know you just consume it and you
move on with your day
your newsletter is actually kind of
interesting because it gives you an
opportunity a small bite-sized
opportunity
for you to do a thing and build up not
only
not only earn from it but also build up
in a way as you do more and more of
these build up
some credentials by having accomplished
these little micro tasks so can you give
us the like that's right know that's my
reason for the outside
did you hear that slight he goes yours
is actually interesting
we should do a collaboration with i'm
sure actually there's a lot with the
hustles kind of ethos that i think
overlaps
um you know as i was mentioning to sean
beforehand you know
you guys like it takes all different
kinds to build a company and you guys
have sort of the
sales you know business dna natively
right
and for me that's very much an acquired
tongue you know where
like i i can emulate you know business
and i can i can run that in an emulation
layer
but like my core os is math you know and
then there's folks who are like the
reverse
who are fundamentally businessmen and
who can get into the tech and get into
the computer science and so on as sort
of a way to do business and
you know one needs both kinds right um
but i think one area of overlap
potentially with the hustle
you know sort of audience is uh that you
know a lot of time
online as we know is just being wasted
right it's being thrown into a meat
grinder i mean like the
sheer number of hours when we really
think about the millions or billions of
hours that are used on social networks
um look i think there's a necessary step
to get people online
i think like on balance it was necessary
but i think one issue is that social
networks were invented and scaled
10 years seven years issued before
cryptocurrency
and so because of that uh you could only
transfer status online
and not value and what that means is
that everything basically boils down to
status games leaderboard what's the most
popular
how many followers how many faves etc
and those appear
locally non-zero sum but are globally
zero sum that's to say
locally it appears it cost me nothing to
give this person a like
but globally it's a zero-sum leaderboard
only one can be at the top
right and that leads to the status games
that you see on twitter and all these
other places that are somewhat
ameliorated in places like reddit where
they use pseudonyms
but it's an issue anyway what's my point
so 1729
uh you know my friend dan romero
actually a while back was tweeting like
you know what's the new hacker news and
i think you guys were
were talking about that um and i think
the new hacker news
for crypto is not just a place where you
come to discuss and do things aimlessly
but something which uses crypto so that
you can actually earn and learn
you know and actually the third is burn
so we actually have another thing proof
of work out
right so basically you're pursuing you
know
truth health and wealth in that order
and i think that's actually the right
priority order right so learn
truth you know determine what's true
pursue health you know because without
that you have really nothing else
and then wealth is important but it's
third and it's important to have that
third you never want to do something
that's untrue to make money or
you know to to sacrifice your long-term
health for wealth i mean whatever losing
sleep one day okay maybe not the end of
the world for a year it's gonna affect
your long-term health you know and
that's actually going to affect
even from a pure dollars and census it's
going to affect your wealth entering
capacity
and your capacity to provide value for
your employees and your shareholders
even if you
if it's the selfless thing to do on a
daily basis on a long-term basis
you want to take care of your health for
the health of those around you so
essentially this was sort of so that
this true health and wealth thing is
this like a personal saying or is this
like the
the is this like the slogan for 17 29
years
for 1729 it's basically i think of as
the new liberte
egalite fraternity okay
uh that's great i know it sounds
ambitious but basically
um as a tripartite motto for a new kind
of state
in the in the fullness of time um and
uh the reason is that um technology
actually allows us to do all three
you know with crypto in particular with
decentralized ledgers
we can can i ask the question in a
slightly different way which is
whenever i'm looking at an investment i
think i asked the founders this my
favorite question to ask the founder is
awesome what is the world let's fast
forward three years what does the world
look like
if this has been adopted what is my what
does my day look like
that's different maybe me as a user but
i would love to hear
your version of that because i think
there is a really
different and a cool new lane that gets
opened up
as something like this gets more adopted
so what does the world look like if this
uh what does my date look like what does
it look like well first is
um rather than just accumulating karma
you're actually accumulating
something of value right so something a
tradable asset
um you're earning cryptocurrency you're
you're you're actually leveling up
yourself imagine if you didn't just gain
i don't know 100 thousand followers but
hundred thousand dollars
in all your posting online right that
would actually give material benefit to
people right now
you know for technical reasons facebook
and twitter
basically capture all the revenue and in
the early 2000s mid-2000s that was
actually a great deal
because they were giving these free
platforms that you could broadcast to
anybody in the world
um and they would maintain everything
for you they give all the hosting
you know the free model was actually a
very good deal relative to the
alternative at that time and so they
just take the cut for doing it
but now today people realize actually
hey all this content that i'm producing
for them all this work that i'm putting
into it the hours into your tweets or
whatever
um you aren't seeing a single dime out
of it there's zero creator modernization
for the most part in these major social
networks
um i'm not saying okay not totally zero
you could put link in bio at instagram
and there's some stuff
but it has lagged right and um
so now we need a kind of a new social
contract a social smart contract
and what that means is basically to make
money online
and not just make money but to learn
things online and not just to make money
and learn but also become healthy and so
if this becomes popular you don't waste
time online or not just waste time you
learn things
um you actually gain crypto credentials
not just cryptocurrencies so like badges
in your wallet which are emblematic or
reflective of your ability to do certain
things for example
you complete five python problems and
you get a badge that says i've completed
five python problems
and you complete you know 10 questions
on
i don't know russian history and you get
that kind of badge right
or the russian language now why that
kind of thing is important is
it totally destroys the concept of a
college diploma
the reason being college diploma is a
very very
coarse-grained um you know kind of
illustration of somebody's skills if
somebody says oh i've got a harvard
degree
or stanford degree right what does that
really mean you know
you have some estimate okay i kind of
know that they you know stanford degree
in computer
science i kind of know what the
curriculum is but this particular person
you don't know what their skills are
actually all their coursework they did
during undergrad
has been basically wasted right and if
instead what you did was
that portfolio that they had every
single problem that they sold was in a
folder on github
so you know they have 25 courses in 10
10 weeks per course and 10 problems per
course
all 2500 problems were organized in
folders on
on github you could see their portfolio
you could drill down and see their
particular skills okay this guy knows
operating systems
she knows compilers um this person knows
machine learning and i can see that
as evidenced by the 15 problems they've
solved with source code online
and especially for a broad discipline
like computer science or electrical
engineering or chemical engineering
you can't simply presume that because
somebody has a degree that they have
that particular skill set
people have strengths in different areas
point is once you
unbundle that or you granularize that
once you give individual measurable
skills
you can see just how much talent you
know or background somebody has in there
oh this person has solved
a hundred different problems on
compilers uh they're actually really an
expert in this area and i've got the
badges to prove it okay
once those badges are in your crypto
wallet just like you log into a website
today and you can load in your
cryptocurrency or unload it
right i think one of the things we want
to do at safety trying is have this sort
of portable
crypto diploma or these crypto
credentials so you could log into a job
board and just start working
because you're automatically qualified
on the base of your credentials right
right now the only thing we can declare
is our interest right i'm interested in
game of thrones
you can't provably declare i know how to
calculate eigenvalues
right i know arnoldii langsos you know i
know you know methods for
large matrices i know how to do graph
layout that type of stuff right
you can't credibly declare that you can
certainly put the words in your cv
but if you guys have hired you know that
that's an unreliable narrator problem
often
right you know people will say so how
does that
similar question but basically like what
i'm understanding with this
is like so right now as it is it's
a much simpler it's not doing everything
you just said it's
basically um here's a here's something
that is just like
silly funny or actually useful i'm gonna
pay you money if you could pull it off
that's right
um and that's in itself that's just like
interesting and fun and neat but the
long-term plan here
is that basically you're going to have
let's say you're building a company
anyone who meets the requirements are
you saying they're going to be able to
log in based off of their task history
and just contribute
workers and get paid for it exactly now
that sounds like
my thing with you is like everything you
sound is crazy but you
you're right a fair bit so it's like
it's like it's
so i have to like i'd like life would be
easier because it's ridiculous if we
could just write you off as crazy we
could just move on with our day
damn it the guy's right so now we have
to take each one of these ideas and
actually say [__]
so this is actually so so let me let me
speak to a few points here right so
basically
like the very short version is 70 trying
is a place where you
make money learn things level up with
technological progressives interested in
building a positive future right so
it's it you know on the east coast for
example
media media businesses have sort of
software engineers as second classes
right they're just guys who build the
app and the writers are kind of the
first class right
um traditionally in tech it's been the
opposite you know the software engineers
are
the you have private place they're
building dropbox or google or whatever
and then the writers are content
marketing
i think here another aspect of safety
giant is they're kind of unified
where we have a product roadmap and we
also have content calendar
and those are really you know side by
side and basically equal pairs
we have a story that we're telling as
we're kind of building this
functionality
and i think one of the things about this
and there's several different angles i
can talk about but
one big thing is uh this is a sort of
reaction against what i think of as the
entropic internet
right so if you know entropy or the
concept of entropy it's like
particles flying in every direction okay
if you go and look at hacker news for
example or twitter
there's something that you can't unsee
once it's been pointed out which is
those 30 links are like a jackson
pollock blah
on on on the on the page right it's just
it's like
guaranteed to just fragment your brain
into a thousand pieces
right um and the opposite of that is
something like
you know what michael nielsen has been
doing with the science of reminding you
know
where you learn something and you don't
just learn it you get
you know reminders at you know one
minute and one hour and one day you know
space repetition right of the same
concept
with a little bit of space repetition it
gets stored in like your permanent
memory banks you remember quantum
computing for example right
so right now what we're doing with the
entropic internet is for just
eating all this junk food which feels
good because it's novelty seeking oh
cool that's cool
oh that's cool oh that's cool right and
you know if you have a really good
memory
then you don't need the space repetition
but most people don't have such a good
memory
and even people who have a great memory
i mean do you remember the thousands of
links that you've seen online no it's
actually more like watching a movie it's
just
it's just sugar it's just candy right if
instead you can be much more
deliberate about a less entropic
internet and essentially a goal for
yourself and you make one high level
decision come to 7029
and then what we do is we basically
serve you content that strengthens you
right sean i i i think that we can take
this in so many ways i want to talk
about media eventually
but where do this is so interesting what
he's like you you want to
yeah like she just threw out this like
meaty thing and we could like chop this
up in like a hundred different ways
there's
so like i want to talk about this
anonymous work thing which is somewhat
like this
i want to talk about this topic and i
want to talk about what you just said
about east coast media i would love to
talk about that sure
what do you want to do so let's just
jump around because i think that's if
this was let's do it like we always do
if this was just us hanging out having a
conversation and the listeners are flies
on the wall
uh that's what people like best so let's
do that so uh yeah what would you say
right now if it's a normal conversation
you'd be like
tell me what the you know let's talk
about media i want to go to this media
thing because you said something
that i see that you're doing and i think
it's smart but
it's so obvious i don't know why you and
others haven't done it which is
i do the same thing i criticize like
east coast media where like the writers
are the stars and a lot of them
are it's like the circle jerk community
um
that i am somewhat part of i owned a
media company and i've hired a lot of
those people
and in silicon valley the engineers are
like the gods where
and both are circle jerk communities
like they both can stink and they both
can rock whatever
so um but you're saying that you're
paying attention to
content now in media i was talking with
you i don't know did we do a call we did
something something
where i was teaching where i was
teaching you about email because you're
like
this email thing is cool and i was like
duh dude
what the hell well i i i remember we had
a call
and i remember you had actually some
insight i don't think it was
quite like oh my god no i i'm teasing
you you
you i i criticized your website i go
dude if you want
email to be part of your website just
make your website like your personal
domain like just make that an email and
that's it got it
yay i understand i understand so the
thing is that um
i was actually building 1729 at the time
but your suggestion of actually having
the subscriber thing on the front page
like subscribe is actually what we did
do
so we did take that suggestion and i
think it's good um
so but but what i'm getting at though is
like why are you all of a sudden caring
about media and
and i and the reason why i'm asking this
is i love media i love content so does
sean
it's a pretty shitty business model like
subscribe subscription's a good business
model advertising is a shitty business
model
but another way of putting it another
way of putting the question is you built
a you know a bio
you know genetic genetics company you uh
you know we're cto of coinbase
early in crypto and the current product
in its product form is a newsletter
right
low tech but you know high reach you
know potentially so
why did you decide to do that of you
know why did you decide to go kind of go
into a space where
uh you know we debate this all the time
you know is media a good space to go
into
why um so i think sam is that what
you're getting at like why did you
decide to launch this product which you
say
you want to know and i want to know what
your version of media is going to be and
like because i don't ever want to leave
this industry but i think the business
model blows
so like if you have if you can save me i
would love that well
okay so lots of lots of things there so
one is that
um i think
let me give it let me give a story a
history and yeah then maybe go from
there so
um you know you can you can date let's
say the modern era of tech different
starting points well let's date it
starting at like 1995 with the netscape
ipo
okay um and you know from 95
to roughly 2008
um you know tech and media basically
ignored each other
or rather media coverage of tech was was
positive you know up until the dot-com
boom and after the dot-com crash
and 9-11 for many years there in the
early 2000s
um you know tech was happening but it
certainly was not a front page story
it's actually hard to remember but you
know if you go back
to even 2008 and you look at like lists
of power centers of the us
silicon valley doesn't actually come up
there because
google was just a search engine facebook
was just a college social network
you know it was growing but it was just
college social network and
uh the iphone hadn't yet come out it was
just coming out 2007 was announced right
and um so the so
so media kind of ignored tech during
this period is occupied with the iraq
war
and you know terrorism and all this
stuff that was a big storyline of the
the 2000s uh and it was you know
obviously there were blogs and stuff
like that and people were using it but
it was kind of a
there's a sideshows like that thing you
kind of you know supporting character
basically
um tech also ignored media and
that that reason is different that's
because terry simmel was at yahoo
and he tried to turn yahoo into a media
company and for an entire
generation of tech founders uh that that
seemed like a very bad model
because you know yahoo failed or i
shouldn't say fail fail didn't go to
zero of course
but relative to google it failed and all
these this entire generation of tech
founders took the lesson that you just
built a pipe
right you built facebook yeah aol did it
too yeah exactly
that's right so facebook dropbox you
know
um you know youtube twitter that entire
generation
of companies basically said we're
neutral pipe we're just going to build a
technology by the way that was hard
enough
that was pretty freaking hard you know
like at that time bandwidth constrained
environment
before all the modern web development
tools that was actually not trivial you
know
so they just focused on that completely
and they said look the users bring their
own content user-generated content right
and um that kind of you know happened
for a while
and then the financial crisis happened
and the iphone happened
and after the financial crisis in you
know 2008 from 2008 to 2012
facebook google apple all started going
totally vertical
and there's a graph called print media
disruption which you can see
which was after the financial crisis you
might you know i showed that on screen
if there's like a video version of this
after the financial crisis print media
dropped the revenue from like something
like 65 billion down to like 17 billion
while google and facebook were just
going vertical like this right and
craigslist of course was also a factor
here it wasn't just you know like
like advertising was also classified
that was a major factor
craig newmark effectively bought them
off with uh the numark foundation stuff
with a lot of grants for journalism like
datajournalism.com
this sort of uh there's like a
surveillance handbook at
datajournalism.com by the way exactly
how to surveil a subject of an article
uh which you can look at to see exactly
how these folks kind of think
um but we uh when we started the hustle
by the way we started it out of
craigslist office
there are a bunch of stories in the
2000s there were negative pieces on
craigslist it wasn't obvious to me
whether or not
the craigslist classifieds were actually
that much worse than newspaper
classifieds i never saw any stats on it
but it seemed motivated in part by you
know
craigslist economic you know attacks on
on media implicit not not intentional
but implicit
i think in part some degree of peace was
bought
with craig then funding a bunch of
journalism i have nothing against craig
you know i don't know him i'm just
saying that i that's that's an
observation
uh craigslist by the way is a wildly
profitable business it's just private so
nobody knows how much money it makes but
it's
it's a very big deal okay what's my
point coming back up the stack
so from 2008 to 2012 tech suddenly
came out of its box which was you know
oh cute gadget manufacturers
over there in palo alto just take over
all of these segments that were
previously the east coast segments like
madison avenue was taking a hit
everybody was looking to cut
costs after the 2008 crisis
entertainment okay let's do that online
rather than going to the movies
all of that type of stuff just shifted
online it's a huge digital shock
right a corona is a second one by the
way um
and so what happened is that you know
tech
and media were basically allied through
2012 to get obama reelected
um and if you look at the late 2012
coverage for example like the nerds go
marching in
december 2012 was sort of the high water
mark of sort of the
tech media alliance and then in 2013
basically the post-election the knives
came out right
um and uh essentially what happened was
media was like okay uh you guys um
are getting way too big for your
britches uh we kind of thought of you
as like just a part of the coalition but
you're coming for the entire enchilada
you know to mix metaphors right
uh and um this was something where
all the negative articles on tech and
tech bros
you can date it exactly to like 2013
2012 um there's even articles at
uh you know valuebag whatever denying
that such a thing as a programmer exists
okay um the same guy the next year is
starting to write you know nasty
articles on like tech bros and
and whatnot right so it's a very crisp
shift okay
and um so so then what happened
basically for the next several years
tech got its head caved in by by media
with the tech lash
something i warned against because i
could see it as like a almost like a
seed investor
i could see this thing brewing and going
viral
in in 2013 and i could see even you know
there's one journal in slate who's like
sort of sort of denounced this thing and
said oh
you know would you look at all these
rich people this is such a silly view of
the world you know we can do so much
more
and then five years later he's calling
for abolish billionaires right you can
actually see the radicalization pipeline
of these folks in real time
and um you know you can you can watch
this happening because
their world is collapsing and they blame
it on tech and it is certainly true that
economically
a lot of that revenue is going to tech
tech didn't try to do it but google and
facebook and twitter took away ads
but not just ads they also took away a
lot of influence and so you had this
sort of
battle of the bulge style reaction you
know in
from roughly 2013 to 2019 with this tech
lash
and these media corporations they
couldn't build
search engines or create social networks
what they could do is write stories and
shape narratives
and do you know the difference between
like a story and you know a product
announcement
well i mean one's objective one isn't it
yeah but a story has a bad guy
i got a hero so go ahead i said and a
hero
yeah yeah yeah but but like you know as
people have said you can build a
religion without god but not without
satan
um and you know so the um
not original to me you know that's
that's a saying uh
and so what happened basically was you
know while tech is busy doing these
pastel colored
product announcements oh you know like
dropbox offers 10 more gigs yay and it's
just a utility
right um media corporations were busy
lining up
to paint tech as bad as evil
and you've heard like 500 different
lines of argument on this right
and every you know uh like gernon
academic was jostling to try to find
that meme
that would like kill these tech
companies once and for all right
and uh you know they've been somewhat
successful in that and
but they also haven't been um what's
happened is a lot of the
older lion tech companies that didn't
have any ideological defenses
but were good at making money got sort
of mentally
colonized right and you know went woke
and um that has resulted in
you know yeah they could make a lot of
money but they didn't have the the meta
level story they didn't have the middle
level narrative
so it's like that saying about uh
economists right
practical men who believe themselves
fully devoid of
external influence are often the slaves
of some dead economist have you ever
heard that
you know that's by john john maynard
keynes i think
um so his point being that these ideas
float around the air
and people are running on scripts that
they don't even realize they're running
on
because media scripts humans just as
code scripts machines right this is
something i had in the ferris podcast
right
so technically unpack that for a second
for somebody who doesn't get it
right off the top you know you know just
the way that you know
uh what is a script in the way that the
media scripts humans
um masks work masks don't work
um okay boomer um every meme
right for example okay you see a bunch
of kids when they're
the k the karen thing yeah the karen
thing you know you see a bunch of kids
when they come out of a movie theater
what is the first thing they do
i haven't seen kids come out of a movie
theater i don't know okay a bunch of
kids coming
here the first thing they do is they
start quoting lines from the movie
right they just reenact what they just
saw on screen
right right and so you know this is
something where
the way to get people to do something
sometimes it is to tell them to do it
but often is just show it being done
right and that is kind of you know peter
thiel's
you know a citation of rene gerard on
mimesis
i think is important like humans are
memetic that's how we acquire language
that's how we align on objectives you
know and i think
that um whether you want to call it
contagious mental illness i think that's
an understudied concept by the way we
know that there's contagious
physical illnesses we know there's
viruses right uh contagious mental
illness well
we've sort of all stuck our brains into
twitter right like
this vat right imagine putting your
brain into a vat
with 300 million other people and
they're all just sending electromagnetic
you know their brain states to you it
feels a little unhygienic if you think
about it that way
right um and in an interesting sense we
sort of
social distance away from each other
offline but we packed close online like
social networking packed clothes
and what that meant was that bad means
you know crazy memes could spread faster
than ever wildfire
whoosh like this right because
everybody's brain was connected over his
brain right
there's you know there's a famous uh
cartoon of this um
you know with the with the stock market
where it shows the medic contagion
with respect to prices you know and it's
like uh
a guy says okay i can't have any more of
this
goodbye and someone overhears and
they're like goodbye bye
bye bye bye bye you know like uh
and then and then there's somebody else
who overhears it and it's like um
i think the stock could really excel and
then someone's like excel
sell sell sell sell
and it's actually really funny right
because um
you know it just sort of conveys these
sort of like traveling waves
of of memes right right now we don't
have great visuals on this we can't
uh we can't do the molecular neurology
of the meme
like we can do the molecular biology of
the gene uh let me explain what i mean
by that
the concept of genetics uh predated
molecular genetics you know like mendel
went into these phenomenological
experiments where
you could see you know like the the pea
plants and so on big a little layer if
you remember that from high school or
what have you
before people understood the
biochemistry of you know
deoxyribonucleic acid and how a gene is
actually represented in the double helix
and all that type of stuff
that awaited kind of the next century
right in the same way i think
dawkins and kind of our phenomenological
understanding of memes
right is something that is ahead of our
molecular neurology
how are ideas represented in the brain
right how are they stored how are they
retrieved how are they accessed
how they communicate people have done
things on this with like you know the
so-called
jennifer aniston neuron right where you
know it appears there's actually
sites in the brain that would actually
store jennifer aniston
like you see something and it just has
you know where you see the words
jennifer aniston you see the image
jennifer anderson you see a video of her
you see brad pitt and it would light up
next to her and so on and so forth for
somebody who follows all this celeb
stuff it's not my thing
but um this is from that uh it's from
paper a while ago when jennifer anderson
was still i think very much in the news
not as much
today right um that concept
seems to also exist to some extent
within neural networks
um you know like the new you know like
the the the ai stuff that's being done
where you can actually seem to um
express
uh like a like an abstract concept where
a neuron replacer i think open ai i
forget who i think is opening i had a
paper on this recently okay
so we're starting to actually get at how
concepts
abstract concepts could be represented
in a quantifiable
scientific way and you know we're not
yet there
but eventually we'll be able to see
things like okay here's this traveling
wave
of ideas memetic contagion here are
ideas that serve as vaccines
against those other ideas right they
block them out because
these ideas are themselves trying to
spread so yeah so how does this
so like i'm going to say like here's the
the the dumb sam version of what you
said which is like
i can convince people to believe certain
things by making them feel certain
emotions and i could do that by
by using sticky viral content which
boils down to funny memes um
and that the internet is still on tap
and then we can all we're all racing to
stake put our
stake in the ground and email is one
great empire to build
is that kind of what you're getting at
well email is one piece of it
right um but yeah but basically you know
there's push notifications
that's just a mechanism of how nodes are
connected but they on a side note on
that i do think that within five to ten
years
in addition to email and text message
your um
ens name will become probably the ensdam
real estate crypto name
will become the third most popular
communications channel
um well i want to talk about that in a
second because that's amazing but to
wrap up the
media thing so to what what did sean say
earlier he was a
he had a good question which was like in
three years what's the world going to
look like
what's your let's say that you are
running which you kind of are
um this small media business maybe one
day it will be a media empire
what do you think that's going to look
like um and like how's that going to
function how's that business model going
to work totally yeah so
um basically i think
uh so you know i'm giving long answers
because i didn't have the time to write
short ones i don't know if that makes
any you know if you've heard that one
yes yeah
yeah it's uh uh i didn't have time to
write a short thing i was too busy doing
the long term
so so excuse my digression and you know
maybe i can edit this down into sound
bytes
or or shorter thesis statements the
short version is basically
tech ignored media for all the reasons i
just described in that story
and over the last six years we've seen
the cost of ignoring media
the story is told and you're the bad guy
okay now um there's another story to be
told
which is uh for example there's a
website called tech journalism tech.com
okay um so a nigerian guy basically
tried to submit this as an op-ed
to a bunch of uh tech journalism outlets
and couldn't get it there and i put up a
prize and he
actually went and did this analysis and
shows that actually
tech is like 30 points more diverse in
the media outlets that constantly
give tech [__] about this right um and
so the um you know another story is that
actually a lot of the owners of these
media corporations are
like literally inherited wealth like
nepotists that right you know
just got the family business from their
father's father's father's father and
uh you know you know another aspect is
they're mostly american
as opposed to the mostly immigrant
nature of tech which is very global and
has an international purview
and so on and so forth there's actually
a number of ways
where uh the narrative of these media
corporations where
they run billboards that literally they
market themselves as truth
on a billboard or democracy like
democracy dies in darkness like that's
how they market themselves on a
billboard or or fairness and balance
right
that's just corporate propaganda
literally by these legacy media
corporations to define themselves as the
literal truth you know and they believe
this you know the brains have been
melted by corporate propaganda to such
an extent
now i don't think any tech company would
be you know people talk about tech
arrogance or i think any tech company
would be so crazy as to market itself as
a little truth
but now actually we have an answer as to
what that literal truth is which is
cryptography
cryptography and especially how the
blockchain actually puts it online
is decentralized truth right it's
mathematical truth it's truth that
anybody has access to
um you know as i mentioned in a previous
podcast basically
everybody knows exactly how much bitcoin
somebody has you know whether you're
palestinian or
israeli democrat or republican that's
not something there's actually
contention over
which is amazing because it's this
trillion dollar piece of international
property that's the kind of thing people
usually fight over
we can use those so what are you
implying peop we're going to be we're
going to be covering that we're going to
be
covering these transactions and we're
going to know well is that i mean
here's what i think yeah here's what i'm
playing here that's only one that's only
one
niche that's an interesting one yeah
yeah okay so step two is defy
where it's not just who owns what
bitcoin but who owns what digital
property digital goods
and that's an enormous swath of the
economy right maybe most of the economy
over time
all property eventually becomes digital
should i clarify why i think that
because that's that's a provocative
statement why does all property become
digital
because much of the physical world
becomes printing
okay so obviously you can print out a
piece of paper right
um if you look at for example the supply
chain or what's going on in robotics
in terms of um like getting food to your
door
okay there's folks who uh will obviously
the restaurant is now pop-up
right uh the delivery you know bit
there's folks who are doing
autonomous cars right or sidewalk
delivery robots which are better in some
ways
there's folks who are doing autonomous
food prep right
and so you could imagine the whole thing
being fully automated
and it's all of robotics and it's all
this electromechanical process
that has no human intervention in which
case it's analogous to just a
print right it's like printing something
out
and i think like robotics is something
which has sort of again sort of have
been happening in our peripheral vision
we kind of know what's going
on boston dynamics and whatnot but what
i think is going to happen is most the
value will be created online and you'll
print it out by essentially invoking
robotics
and i think that's the next you know
this decade we're going to see more and
more of that you're starting to see
actually
robots in the field like these robot
dogs i think we're going to see way more
of that and it's going to come pretty
quickly
because once a robot can do something
you've turned labor into capital
because it's all electricity and the
value you create
and say i'm sorry
i'm installing that premise okay all
property becomes digital so that's the
second phase right
you know who owns what bitcoin and then
you know who owns what loans
bonds stocks assets all the type of
stuff okay
but the third phase is most interesting
to me and with that is it's related to
something called crypto oracles
so many of these contracts over here in
the second phase you're doing bets on
um you know will
this price go up or down or more
interestingly
uh will the temperature go up um in
you know this uh this this farmland so i
need to pay out this insurance because
there's a drought
okay that's like an example of a smart
contract which combines
a financial aspect and a fact about the
world
right for something like that to happen
that was kind of similar to the business
model of like the climate corporation
like climate.com if you remember that
right
for something like that to work the
smart contract needs access to data
about the outside world which is not
purely financial
okay and uh that's the crypto oracle
problem where basically oracle's
broadcast data on chain and they sign it
and they say
i'm reporting that this is true i the
weather channel i'm saying that it's 82
degrees in pokey today at this time
right and i give a timestamp
like temperature feed and this is
happening not just for temperature but
it's happening for
um you know crime statistics or not just
individual crimes from which statistics
are calculated
it's happening for medical records right
so a hospital wouldn't just say we have
a thousand chronovirus patients it
actually has a feed
of this patient at this time this
patient at that time um
redfin or zillow doesn't just publish
aggregate stats it actually has a feed
of which real estate transactions are
happening at what time
okay and from this accurate stats can be
computed but you can also drill down to
individual rows and diligence them
what's the point right now all of these
feeds of data that i'm describing
are siloed you know the the real estate
data happens here
the medical data happens here the price
data happens here the temperature data
happens
here but what i call the ledger of
record is essentially the integration of
all these crypto oracles
and the reason they go on chain is that
it's profitable you can trade off of
that information right you can make
money off of that information so each
individual oracle
goes on chain and it's subsidized so
you've got a micro incentive to put it
online that's not some
macro you know high floating you know
concept but the macro concept is as
all of those individual oracles go into
this thing i call the ledger record
you now have cryptographically
verifiable facts about the world
you have a digital history an
unalterable history you can tell what
happened when
and in a sense this is kind of just the
next step in the sense that we've got
all these tweets
right which actually give us a
reasonable i shouldn't say perfect
but some degree of the intellectual
history of
you know the last decade right uh if the
twitter database was downloadable and
eventually
you know either something like it either
it will be or someone will scrape it or
something like that because
you know storage just keeps improving so
you can store all of twitter on a
micro drive of 2035 or something like
that that database
could be analyzed in all kinds of ways
to determine people's moods
what people talked about all the memetic
contagion stuff that we just talked
about you could actually look at all of
that and visualize that we can't easily
see that right now because the data set
isn't open
in the future with this ledger of record
it would be and you'd be able to
establish what happened at what time
and so that is the sense sam in which
you go simply from just who owns what
bitcoin
to who owns what smart contracts to who
said what thing at what time like what
facts were asserted
and that is actually a very powerful
thing where we start to actually
displace
a corporate media corporation as the
font of truth
with cryptography instead all right let
me pause there i know it's a whole
download but maybe i can express it
better i'm going to summarize some of
the some of the interesting ideas that
you brought up so i think
uh and you could take drink of water you
deserve it um so
so i think one of the interesting things
was the kind of observation of
me first media ignoring tech and then
sort of as tech became more powerful
ignoring media and what you're
identifying is that
technology companies are going to
realize the power of media meaning
being able to shape the narrative rather
than just being the villain in the
narrative
continue this is the third swing of the
pendulum
that's one interesting trend if you're
building a company right now that's very
much worth considering
uh yeah and in order to do that you're
gonna have to flex different muscles
uh storytelling memes packaging you know
different things
you don't have to do once i give you my
meme i mean own a media corporation or
be owned by one
there you go uh and so so that's that's
one interesting kind of
point you brought up second one is this
idea of
empirical truths enforced by economics
so
today uh media companies claim to be the
truth they market themselves as the
truth it was just you know sort of the
corporate propaganda
and there's all kinds of hypocrisy
underneath that so uh you identified
many of them the
let's say criticizing diversity yes not
being diversity
not being diverse yourself uh
criticizing you know hating billionaires
yet
the media companies owned by billionaire
families that are passing it down from
one child to you know
one father to the next son so there's
all these hypocrisy underneath that
uh and how do you get away from that
while there is this
general movement of all things becoming
digital it's not just software it's the
world sort of
uh you know the whole world becomes
software and as the whole world becomes
becomes digital assets become digital
contracts become digital
data and news reporting becomes digital
and you have this idea of crypto oracles
which are the
journalists or media companies of the
future where if we need to know what
happened what is the truth who won the
game who got elected
you know in order to enforce these
betting markets or these prediction
markets or these stock markets
um then you then they will be rewarded
through these sort of micro economic
incentives for being accurate
or punished very able summary but let me
offer a few asterisks
so i think the vision of the future is
oracles and advocates
right so redefine a reporter
as like a sensor right a sensor that
essentially writes data on chain
okay which can literally be um like like
a machine
that just takes a temperature sense and
writes it on chain right
and the thing is you might think that's
trivial but hey that would actually in
aggregate if you had lots of them
give you a cryptographically provable
record that you could use in for example
discussions about climate change right
so
the weatherman becomes a sensor who
tells the weather that's right
that's right or but this but this this
is kind of a little
the okay so i i understand what your
your vision is here but it's missing a
whole lot wait wait wait wait wait wait
let me give you the second part of it
before you because you might be right
okay the first layer that base layer is
the raw facts
cryptographical attestations right from
from
sensors and the sensor could be lying to
you of course it could be saying the
temperature is 80 when it's actually 30
but it's got a digital signature so you
can see its track record you can
involve other kinds of things there
right um you can match it up you can
audit it other people can audit it so
you can have a second thing that's
auditing
you know one out of a hundred of the
measurements of the first guy um
there's a hyper geometric distribution
which is like you know auditing um
things off an assembly line like pick a
ball and see if it's corrupted or not
uh but then the second layer is uh
advocates on top of those oracles okay
so these are humans and you just assume
that a human has an editorial judgment
you know why because not just
what they write it's what they write
about and now the selection function
of what specific facts they choose to
include is itself visible
right editorial judgment is now
quantifiable because you have this
layer of the raw facts that are on chain
and then
narrative becomes tangible because it's
which facts you actually cite in your
story
okay and so the selection function
is basically just like a ranking
algorithm for a social media site
that selection function actually is now
quantifiable but you can see not just
what was included
but crucially what was omitted the
so this seems like but this seems like
an entire so okay so what you're going
to do is
uh 1729 you're i don't going to hire
about
1729 for this whole thing right yeah i
know i'm just making that
i'm just using that yeah your your media
empire you're gonna hire 200 engineers
to build this um
um what did you call it the um the um
lecture record um and then you're gonna
hire 200 journalists to
editorialize sorry you're not quantum
journalist
advocates uh to editorialize some of the
the facts correct no so i've got a
different so it's actually useful
i would call what you just said like uh
i don't mean it's a bad way but sort of
like the real world looking model
um here's at least what i'm planning to
do which may well fail but you know at
least just
what i'm thinking about so first is it's
decentralized media
so what i want to do is invest in lots
of individual
uh you know diverse influencers
pseudonymous voices around the world
okay so basically you know
everything that's not brooklyn books you
know
all these other voices that are
underrepresented in our conversation
ideologically demographically
internationally technologically you know
like scientific depth being brought to
bear
those are kind of folks that i want to
fund is that right chosen by you you
know
decentral you know you know what i mean
yes yes that's right but
but the the like all the tools and stuff
that we use for selection funding like
the yc style safe equivalent and so on
um all those will be public so i want
people to pick it up and copy it and so
on and so forth right
so i'm not at all proprietary about that
i'm just trying to set an example
uh for what it's worth sort of similar
like you know last night
um you know i tweeted out like for the
code relief thing in india
and you know the notion co and the um
the uh actually the hubspot founder
uh dharmesh actually um rt that so it
kind of gave a template that they could
then just use
and that's that's what i seek to do
right um
and uh you know the goal being to
basically bootstrap a bunch of these
voices okay call that one component
the second component is to bootstrap the
technology which is to say
uh figure out like what the right
version of using crypto oracles in
content is
okay um maybe that's going to require a
few years of compounding maybe i just
write the articles
on what that vision of the future is and
i'm not smart enough to build it
but one of my you know you know
portfolio companies or readers or
something like that
is um because you know we all uh it's
all it's all a relay race right
you know you hand the baton and maybe
someone else can figure out something
you did it and so on right so kind of
open sourcing my thinking
on how we can get to a better model of
you know truth right out there
and then third is writing a story um so
so first is
you know like the the writers and the
the people who are writing these tasks
second is of the technology technology
for kind of creating the task creating
the content and third is the story which
is
i have a book uh the network state which
i've been i'm a perfectionist so i edit
the chapters and i edit them and edit
them so i put the first one
up at 729.com you know how to start a
new country i think it's
done pretty well you know like uh it's
it's uh it's got a lot of good feedback
and i think it's stimulated some
thinking and essentially the idea is
you know um how do you start a new
country
well when there's no land the short
answer is rather than try to like
take over a peninsula or a you know
piece of territory
or you know or or declare or conversely
take over like a oil platform
near england and call yourself sea land
right instead
you have a community that you build in
the cloud and they go and take pieces of
land all around the world
uh which are like you know cul-de-sacs
or apartment complexes and so on you
network them together
such that it's something which may
eventually have a scale of hundreds of
thousands or millions of people
and the footprint of a contiguous state
but it's discontiguous and it's
networked on the internet
right so that's the third part which is
a story so it is not
simply content or technology
is anybody do you think that is there a
project out there or do you feel like
there's anybody out there who's doing
that taking that approach to how do you
start a new country
create a community in the cloud and then
have this like decentralized pods or
hubs all around the world
where those people actually concrete i
think it's a 20-year project
and you know basically uh my my
one-liner on this is
2000s were the tech companies 2010s
crypto protocols
2020s startup cities 2030s network
states
okay so company protocol city
state i think that's where we're going
so
we are in this startup cities phase
right now so let's transition to that
real quick so yeah
uh what is a startup city is this like
sam leaving
san francisco moving to austin you know
the mayor of miami
actively recruiting candidates like a
startup ceo
would and and hiring away great talent
into miami is that what a startup city
is to you or is it something else
yeah so what's great about the term is
it encompasses kind of three definitions
right
the first is just a city where startups
happen which is where what san francisco
used to be
um you know uh the okay nowadays it's
just you know like
somebody who's choosing san francisco
for a startup i crinkled my eyebrows
you know i mentioned it before before
the pandemic i said it was like choosing
java
you know proven but kind of kind of
sucks and it's like okay you don't know
new languages and you know i'm not sure
about your productivity and this or
whatever
but now it's like choosing oracle for a
new company you know
which is like right basically you're
just getting locked into this horrible
cost structure of declining product when
far better options are available i
question their judgment you know
um so the first definition is a city
where startups just happen
okay the second is a city that acts like
a startup which is
miami now under suarez which is amazing
okay
and the third definition is a city
that's a startup itself
like prospero.hn or cul-de-sac.com or
the various startup cities that
pronamos.vc is investing in
and um the the thing is i think
uh you know obviously when i when i said
2000 tech companies 2010 scripted
protocols 2020 startup cities 2030's and
upper states
that's sort of when that exponential
starts right
what is the analog of bitcoin in 2010
it's startup cities in 2021
right okay where go ahead
uh i was going to ask you a different
question maybe that's a good one just a
good one to drop on your listeners
bitcoin 2010 was a pretty good buy or
whatever you know yeah exactly that and
i
actually wanted to know you got into
crypto early on
i want to know actually what was the uh
you know where were you kind of when you
first how did you actually first hear
about it was it the white paper that you
stumbled through
a conversation with a friend so how did
you hear about it
how did you get yes and then how long
did it take you to sort of like
you know the mind virus infected you
completely and you're like oh wait this
is actually
gonna work so i would love to hear that
from you yeah so
you know i have to recollect the exact
timeline but basically
it was something where i'd been thinking
about economics and money
after the financial crisis because
everything broke and so you start
thinking more deeply
about you know the system that you just
thought was functional
just shattered into a million pieces and
or just didn't work
and um i'd been thinking about like how
the true definition of
money is energy in a sense of
j-o-u-l-e-s
joules like visualize like an iphone you
know
coming together like like the rare earth
elements and the glass
and the aluminum and so on and this and
the the silicon just rush like this
molecular assembly
and how much energy would it actually
take you to assemble that from its
constituent parts you know
like in chemistry you can you can
quantify this you know with like uh
various various chemical processes how
much how much input energy do you need
to catalyze it
um or to make the reaction run and
um so that was like something i was
thinking about because if you could
reduce the energy cost of assembling
something like a phone
over time you had genuinely reduced the
price
right that's a genuine reduction because
humans were able to do this thing more
efficiently today than we were in the
past
and that'd be the kind of deflation that
you want joule deflation
where because of technology we've
actually made this thing cheaper to do
than we used to be able to do right
um now i've been thinking about this and
then you know one of my friends you know
basically like you know i'd write these
essays or whatever uh
but just this is before i was a public
you know public figure
that sounds like anything just you know
my academic friends was like okay you
should
you know look at this bitcoin thing and
uh i forget exactly when that was 2010
or 2011
but basically um i thought it was really
interesting because it was also using
energy you know in a sense a different
way
to kind of support value um
but it was doing something i thought was
very counterintuitive the most counter
to the thing about bitcoin at the time
to me
was that the extra computation was not
going into increasing the number of
transactions per second but rather
increasing the security of the system
that was a design decision that was
totally foreign to
everything we had learned about scaling
out systems and going parallel and so on
and so forth
that was that was something which took
me a while to wrap my head around
not that i thought it was bad i just i
was like i just don't understand this or
for example the fact that all blockchain
addresses were public
essentially he had stepped out of the
box of
what i thought a distributed system
should be you know
like had made certain design decisions
now in retrospect
uh these are genius moves but like
having all your transactions out there
in public
on chain um just would have seemed like
a
like a feature that you wouldn't be able
to give up right but with the
pseudonymity it's like okay
and then now with zero knowledge we
figured out with zcash and other things
how to add back that privacy right
um so i i followed bitcoin but it was
actually only after the 2011 crash and
recovery
that i was like okay this thing really
has legs
um and i wrote in late 2012 i actually
had a
course at stanford i gave where i talked
about bitcoin and i'm like i'm not sure
if
bitcoin is the one that wins but it is a
very powerful
tech um that is like something in that
class will be a big deal
right and i think both were correct
statements i could find the exact pdf or
whatever if you want
um and so that was around the time that
coinbase also got going and actually
brian and fred and i i
think we first met january 2013 very
very very early on in the history of
coinbase
um and actually like i used the queen
bees api in a class that i taught
that year um and in a mooc course
and uh you know basically that was
kind of my story of getting into bitcoin
and crypto um then 2013 boom of course
happened
but it was basically the crash from 32
down to two dollars in 2011 and the
subsequent recovery up to like 10 bucks
in 2012 that convinced me the thing had
staying power because it's very rare
that you have something endure a 90 plus
drop
and then come back right that's
extremely rare um
you uh so you you def you you
you taught you were a professor correct
yeah
um you were a lecturer i think there was
some article i have no idea if it's true
that
uh you were considering joining the fda
uh
um was that true yeah i mean or rather i
was i was
interviewed for uh a very senior role
um and sure i probably could have been
at least number two that was on the
table uh but i
i chose not to i mean it's now a few
years later i don't usually
like kiss and tell or whatever you know
but the point the point the point is is
that you
you have this like academic side of you
and
which is fascinating you have this
crypto guy
part of you as a partner which is part
investor
still part academic but you also have
this third part of viewers which is that
you've built companies so you you helped
build
you this is like traditional like this
is the most normal
part of you which isn't even nor like
like the most
normal part of you helped build like a
50 billion dollar company called
coinbase so
the most normal part of you uh i used
when
i'm freezing my embryos and we just
found out that like one of our potential
children just had like down syndrome and
like oh [__] that's the most normal part
of you is that
you you built that [__] right
well it's funny which is it's funny
because i uh
for your audience yes i think that's
probably true which is weird because
that's not normal right
right and so i guess uh on the
what i'm curious about is on the on the
tim ferriss podcast
you use one of the more baller phrases
to say that you're rich
use post-economic i didn't use that
phrase tim did but
it's a it's a good phrase it was the
most baller phrase that i've ever heard
of like post-economic like to the point
where money doesn't
like you're beyond that and because
i care about money and it's interesting
to me beyond just like you can buy nice
[__] but it's like you can think about
stuff that you normally wouldn't be able
to think about
where has most of your success financial
success
come from this weird part of you that
is this crypto investor and got in early
or from the traditional part
of building companies and there's a
reason why i'm asking but
i'm curious what the answer is i think
i'm
uh you know i like to think myself as a
pragmatic ideologue
where i have a horizon where i have my
eyes set on this long-term goal of
transhumanism and transcendence but
then i'm willing to be as pragmatic as
possible in the short run and execute
and go down to do lists and so on for
that north star
right which i'm always conscious of and
i wake up in the morning and i go to
sleep at night and i think about that
and i think i think that's basically uh
sorry as you can see i think that's
evident you you kind of proved that when
we
we asked you about 1729 and
uh when you talked about it you talked
about essentially disrupting you know
education making
uh making it so that when people spend
their time online they're not just
frivolously scrolling feeds they're
actually learning and earning and
burning calories
but then if you go to the product it is
the v1
kind of crawl where you say okay what's
the simple building block that we need
to do that
let's send a newsletter every day with a
micro task that
people can do to learn something and
earn a little bit of money
and so i think you have i think you
embody that exact
idea of like what's the extreme
long-term north star and then what is
today's building block in order to
move forward and that's why and that's
why i was getting like
what the hell are you up to well it's
funny but uh
it's funny well so let me talk about
that for a second that is
absolutely an acquired language where i
have
learned that you need you know moritz
talks about this half jokingly
as you know every app needs one of the
seven deadly sins
you know like lust greed sloth gluttony
wrath pride uh i forget the other ones
right
um but i think it's close right and um
so the you know you know tinder is lust
right
and twitter is wrath and arguably early
google which is pretty actually you know
that's pretty high brow
like search you know but arguably that's
sloth you know um
and you know uh then ubereats or
or doordash is bloody i love those
companies don't give your i'm not trying
to diss any of them right
um and uh
so you know the those hooks
basically i think you need to deliver a
visceral instant
benefit to somebody right where in a
second
you can explain what it is okay a
newsletter that pays you right
earn bitcoin for submitting a form in a
minute
right so instant benefit if you can't
give that to somebody instantly then
it's too complicated you know
rarely there's exceptions you know
rarely there's things that
um have a very end loaded benefit you
know like
things like ethereum or rome
research.com for example
you know that rewarded an academic
mindset at the beginning it was very
long term right
but even ethereum for example there was
like a speculative upside you know which
was the visceral short-term thing
where you could align the short-term
mentality with the long-term mentality
um but i have to bring you back go ahead
go
call this bring your best go ahead yeah
yeah i gotta bring it back to the
original question which was
basically i was asking i'm like did you
get wealthier from
this bitcoin stuff or from building the
company stuff and i have a reason for
asking
um i don't usually like disclose my like
percentages or something like that but
let's say i've done
well from both i've been fortunate from
both um
it's interesting because as an investor
you have
um it's one percent
or less of the work it's 10 to 20
of the return but at zero percent of the
control
you know and you know i have never been
like a
tech guy in the sense of um actually you
know there's people who talk about
oh you know i had a commodore 64 really
early on i was programming you know and
so on
that's actually that was actually never
me um i i played video games a lot when
i was a kid
but i was a math guy right that's
actually the angle that i came into it
from you know i was into
you know like math and physics you know
growing up
and you know feynman lectures and all
the type of stuff
and you know thought that i was going to
be maybe like a stats professor
or or applied mathematics professor or
something like that
um and so computers were always just a
tool
and business was always just a tool only
later
to you know the reason i got into you
know genomics or clinical genomics the
reason i did a startup
was uh and i'll come back to your point
i know you're you've got a good thing
the reason i did that was
in academia if you raise 10 million
dollars in a grant
raises in the right term you get a 10
million grant and each row of data costs
a thousand dollars to collect
you can only do 10 000 rows before you
run out of money
right whereas if you're making even 10
on a row you can collect
a much larger sample and make a much
bigger difference for the world right
because you can actually do the data and
also that large sample thing
so the thing is that the zero percent
control
even though i am an investor and i think
i've done
fairly well at it and so on i invest on
an ideological basis
i invest in the world that i want to
build and there's probably things which
are you know good financial investments
that um you know i i i just i'm just not
interested in something if it's if it's
just making money
i can sort of force myself to be in that
headspace
uh but but i i have to force myself you
know yeah the reason i was just asking
was just i just think that you're
the i mean you're like supposed to be
this you're the stereotype of you is
that you have all these odd and unique
frameworks that create this brilliant
ideas
that's cool i i dig that but what i was
curious about like
just what's your life um philosophy
towards certain things specifically how
do you think about execution for example
well it was just like did were you just
like well i'm just gonna go
and like make this company sell it get
the bag now i can do all this crazy wild
[__]
and everything else is upside and like
and that's why i'm wondering because
like
if that is your strategy i actually
think that's kind of cool because
there was some practicality and then
like genius stuff comes out afterwards
and it's interesting i was curious like
in that sense i'm not capable of
i should say i capable of it i
i i didn't just do a job for the sake of
doing a job to get the money to then do
the next thing
um i really believed in both you know
council
and you know crypto and and you know
earn and coinbase
um and so like that's how i could put in
that level of energy and like
you know buffett has this concept of um
i don't agree with a lot of his stuff
nowadays actually but this concept was
as good as like you know if you're
if you're waiting to do what you want uh
it's like you know waiting to make love
at like 70 or something like that you're
just deferring it just doesn't work like
that right you should start
you know working on it now tll says
concept of how do you achieve your
10-year goal in six months you know
so yeah i think that what i tried to do
is
advance short-term goals you know maybe
a sinuous path right maybe a winding
path
but i had that long-term kind of vector
that i'm that i'm going towards
and so the short-term stuff was never oh
let me make the money and move on
maybe that might have been smarter to do
like d.e shaw did something like that
right like uh it's it's
you know d isha d shaw is the guy who
created the
the hedge fund yeah the hedge fund they
put a ton of the money into protein
folding
yeah so like and shaw's famous because
that's where bezos
worked and uh was yeah exactly
he built out this indeed shaw was like
hey are you sure you want to do this
yeah yeah yeah
exactly right so i mean there's a lot of
effect to effective altruism people who
are like this
um i would argue that the effective
altruism people miss one very important
thing which is that
it is the production by people of goods
that actually makes them feel
they deserve things like if you haven't
built you feel guilt
i think it's a very powerful concept
right if you haven't built you feel
guilt so if it's just handed to you
then you don't actually feel like you
deserve it and that leads to
a sense that nobody deserves it and
everybody's things should be taken down
right
so um i think that emergency aid is
actually very good but like
industrialized aid where it fosters a
sense of dependency is
is bad you know easterly and levine have
written about things like this
but recursing back up the stack they do
this concept of
you know work hard make a lot of money
and then spend it on altruism for
example right
and i think that's a reasonable strategy
but i find it like holding your breath
you know um and i i only worked on those
things that
had meaning for me along the way but
were leading to a greater meaning thing
and i've been fortunate enough to do
that by the way you know like
one thing i was just mentioning to sean
um is that
it's hard for me to necessarily give
advice to folks on the very macro
sometimes because in many ways the world
has just become more biology like
okay um if you were a
person who was a nine to five morning
person who liked routine who liked you
know
structure who wanted to hit the same
button every day who wanted
work-life balance and to come home to
the family
and you know like have dinner at the
same time every night and so on and so
forth
the mid 20th century was awesome for you
um because that was kind of the peak of
centralization homogeneity routinization
structure is also by the way the peak of
like you know mass murder and so on
within like china and russia and whatnot
both those are related to centralization
but in the us at least like a decent
quality of life that was like the best
centralized model
in the world right whereas the rest of
the world wasn't wasn't doing so well
under that degree of centralization and
uh and now we're kind of in the opposite
thing where it's like
favoring night people who are
asynchronous
um you know rather than hitting a button
the the same button for 20 years at a
factory
you're hitting a different key every
second you know like you're just
generating
like different information um your your
day can be extremely varied you know one
day
like covet has kind of locked us inside
but your day online can be extremely
varied you know do one thing one day
podcast another day uh maybe play a
video game or
you know basically the entire diversity
of the human experience is a click away
you know um and also the uh
you know you're rewarded now for
diversity of thought and an opinion
in a way that you know if now that
everybody's a content producer
uh the more differentiated your content
the sort of higher the rewards you get
versus if you're in the previous era
there was
not everybody was a content producer
everyone's a content consumer you just
go home sit down watch the box
and um and if you try to sort of stray
out of line you weren't necessarily
going to find your other
find other people who had the same
convictions as you
um and so you know it sort of paid to
just toe the party line in a bigger way
than it does today
where actually will standing out today
it's interesting because i think we are
in the middle of a
um you know the battle of the bulge
which that was
it's basically like germany's
counter-attack and the waiting days of
the war
which is actually a pretty ferocious
counter-attack but
ultimately in the long sweep of history
was just a counter attack and the long
sweep was there right
and um what i think we have now is a
strong counter-attack in favor of
conformity
by both you know kind of like the book
contingent and like
you know ccp right and so i think like
actually
it's going to be a quite a fight because
in my in my model of kind of like these
memes and and things all battling each
other in this gigantic
continent this cloud continent um one of
the most powerful memes
is a meme that says there should be no
other memes before me so you said
something that i want to i want to go to
you said
the world is becoming more biology-like
uh meaning
uh so what does that mean what does that
mean that means that
um from nine to five it is you know
either like tweets or surges of work
right from day people it's like night
people are async you know
from uh status quo bias to disruption
bias
you know from um
you know sort of the physical world to
the informational world the theoretical
world like ideas
matter more ideas can shape the world
more you know
um all those kinds of things
in many ways you know for example
something like soylent okay um
itself like i i like the company and you
know rob reinhart the founder and his
friend and so on
um i prefer like a keto version of
soylent of which one of them exists
okay but as minus the keto thing the
concept
of just not having to think about it so
i can just do more math
or more programming or you know just
more content
that's like i love that right that's a
very biology kind of thing right
and now of course i recognize that you
know there's better forms of food like
salads and so on
but of course there's worse forms of
food like uh candy bars
right and so if you compare it against
you know what's better then you you'll
miss the fact that many people who are
busy don't eat well and to eat a candy
bar rather than a salad
you know and so this is actually like
basically it improves baseline health
you know in theory if it was more keto
or whatever right um
and so that kind of thing is something
where it fit my preferences
and because of that i invested in it and
the world just sort of adopted that
or like crypto you know fit my
preferences
for okay it should be programmable it
should be decentralized there should be
you know like you shouldn't have
somebody be able to do bailouts and so
on and the world became more
decentralized and so
so in some sense that prediction of the
future is just something where
the world is sort of fitting those
preferences you know um and that's
something that's hard to kind of clone
i don't know if that makes any sense
yeah that makes a ton of sense
if you were i don't know 21 today
um
i want to give one asterisk which is in
many ways though a lot of these
businesses do not fit my preferences
like instagram and you know instagram's
a great company but like
going and taking lots of selfies outside
or
you know like that seems like something
you would do bro yeah yeah i'm a very
private person in that come on yeah yeah
no no
like you know i actually tweeted on this
before the pandemic like
um instagram is for people who go
outside
is for depressed intellectuals you know
like
can i um go ahead the reason why can i
explain
what you look like right now um like i'm
in a
i'm in a dungeon here you're you're
supposed to be this like
big shot crypto entrepreneur guy
you have what looks like a like a super
super old camera zero lighting
uh just looking down at like your video
setup is so
horrible i thought it was gonna be the
best i need to actually get that set up
so actually i am solving that
um so i've got a studio and so on that
i'm doing
um but basically like
you know economics we caught him in
transition he's he hasn't he hasn't
set up the full remote workstation yet
yeah yeah i haven't i haven't done all
that yet
uh partly because i do have the blue
yeti or whatever i did get that so
people nag me into doing that
um it's sort of something where i go
zero or a hundred
you know on something and you know so i
just use the defaults unless i like
actually engage
and so uh you know i'm just learning
acoustics and i'm learning
we're talking [__] a month ago you're
absolutely right though you're right
go ahead and then okay these guys flew
out to our houses and they built us
these studios for us because they were
fans of the podcast so we
literally didn't know anything we still
don't know anything we we didn't know
how to put this together ourselves
either
uh and now sam's like acting like we did
this
no i'm making fun of him because he's
like well you know instagram's great but
it's not really for me
yeah yeah you can figure that out yeah
no it's funny a shocker
well it's it's interesting because i
will value something
once it has a dot product with
like my north star right so like the dot
product you know the inner product
in um in in linear algebra it's like you
know here's a vector here's another
vector and how much do they line are
they is it just at right angles or is
there some alignment right
and uh so the reason that i'm going to
be improving
i think dramatically hopefully audio and
video production is
i need the content to tell the story to
build a future
right right so that i'm going to get
good at that hopefully because
we need to but before then i just felt
of it as sort of being an exhibitionist
and it was like not uh you know not my
thing
right uh so i was gonna ask you if you
were 21 today what would you be
like what would 21 year old biology
today let's say you don't have the
tracker you don't have the name
you don't have the funds to be investing
and uh
you know having a big platform to speak
on just just yet what would 21 year old
you be focused on how would you be
spending your time
um so what would i do uh
first skills wise i would get really
good at computer science and statistics
uh first and the reason is that every
domain
has algorithms and data structures which
means that computer science and stats
are valuable anywhere
you can walk into walmart and you start
writing down
code for uh shopping carts and you know
baskets and pricing and so on you can
walk into american airlines and do that
for
you know flight scheduling you could
walk into pfizer
and start writing about vats you know
for drug preparation and
you know like a pharmaceutical
manufacturing right um
reaction connects all that type of stuff
and of course each of these areas will
have
domain knowledge you know but computer
science and statistics are universal
language and i mean
cs and stats i don't mean just like
learning programming
and uh you know how to invoke library
calls i mean actually understanding the
concepts and really wrestling with them
okay um and the reason is it's sort of
like
what physics was to the early 20th
century cs and stats is to this century
because
physics was awesome for you know
understanding the natural world
all these physicists could you know in
the heyday of physics go and kick in the
doors of any discipline and be like ha
i'm going to write down some equations
and just change your life you know
because you're doing this in a
phenomenological way and
and we can do it way better um and
uh now today because so much of the
world is a constructed virtual world
you know because we're interacting with
it on screens you know something like
cryptocurrency is a constructed virtual
world
right social networks are constructed
virtual world so are video games cs and
stats becomes i mean
it was valuable before but it's even
more valuable today so that's a
foundational kind of thing
and um then you know
in terms of domains to get good at uh i
would find something
you know it sounds funny to put it this
way but like
an area that you really care about for
some reason you know and there's
but but that's also a line you know the
ikigai concept because
yeah so like the four things i i may not
remember them fully but it's like
what you're good at what the world needs
uh what you can make money at
um and uh and what you have fun what's
your favorite fun doing that's right
exactly
that's right so thank you guy concept
finding what that is so after you build
that base of skills
right um with cs and stats by the way
you can understand finance because
it's crypto it will all become crypto
you can understand genomics because
the acs gs and ts on screen you
essentially have
a theoretical like foundation in any
area you walk into
and then from that other concepts can be
layered on top if that makes any sense
right
so it's like a general purpose computer
it's a general purpose set of
principles then domains uh
today genomics big robotics big
crypto of course big um i think an
underappreciated area
is going to be relocation permanent
international migration you know that's
why i did teleport a while back digital
nomadism is going to be huge
uh being like there's a thousand pieces
of the tool chain for allowing people to
go more mobile
you know uber and airbnb uber is go down
you know to the coffee shop
but the next step is uber around the
world right how do i just
boom pick up stakes and just move
internationally right now
as quickly as i can for as low a cost as
i can i think
that's that's a big area that people
haven't really thought as much about as
they will
and i think post-vaccination the
post-vaccination world
a lot more people value their freedom to
exit that's why folks are going to miami
and so on like when you're cooped up in
a room
you want to burst free and so the
counter reaction of that is going to be
this great migration in fact i wrote
about this in 2013
there's a article i wrote called
software is reorganizing the world where
essentially i said
um because the internet is breaking
geography because
you're closer to people who are three
thousand miles away than your next door
neighbors
uh the underlying premises of the city
and the nation state are being
invalidated let's say geographical
proximity no longer leads to cultural
proximity
and therefore you know the the uh
assumption that people in the shared
geography will share the same law and
customs is no longer applicable
and what it's going to result in is
these cloud communities eventually
migrating
and materializing into the physical
world and forming cloud cities and
eventually cloud countries
as that's now i think with kovitz
starting to happen um crypto is a big
component of it because those cloud
communities can actually have their own
currencies
okay remind me why i got in this room go
ahead sorry one second you said
geographic proximity is not is no longer
linked to cultural
proximities he said it was that the
phrase yes that's a powerful one which
is
uh explain that for somebody who's never
heard you say that before
sure okay so if somebody lives in a city
in an apartment building they often
don't know their next-door neighbors may
not even recognize the person who's
living 50 feet away from them
right literally this person is living
eating sleeping there but you walk down
this hallway it's all
closed doors right it's basically as if
you lived in
a a data center you know like with
virtual machines you know like
you cut up a server into a bunch of
virtual machines and all siloed and
compartmentalized and isolated from each
other right so you go and you live in
this box
you don't know who's next door you don't
know who's above you don't know who's
below you don't know who's left or the
right if you don't recognize the people
in the hallway
but who do you recognize you recognize a
person from 3000 miles away who you're
laughing with on snapchat or
you know like video chat or anything
like that you recognize
that guy on the other side of the world
who you're arguing with you know
your social network your friends and
your enemies or whatever you know your
friends and your frenemies
like they're just scattered around the
world you know some of them might be
geographically close by but even that is
pointillistic
you know it's like okay this person this
building this person this building this
was this building
and i don't know anybody in between you
know right i i mean i
i buy into that like i've got so many
friends who i consider actually dear
close friends that they're just internet
i call my internet friends and i
i i have only met them once or twice
soon we'll just drop the whole internet
friends
part and we'll just yeah it'll just be
like yeah now at this point the majority
of my friends are internet friends
so that that's just called my friends
now at this point right by the way
pointillistic
i know that sounds like uh maybe it's
not a word i made up it's actually like
a reference to like art
um so whatever it's like lots of little
points you know discreet parts here but
uh what the the nitpick here is or
it's i actually agree with you but i
challenge my belief because
um like all three of us
i think you in particular in your own
bubble but really we're all
in our in this little bubble of like um
uh the future it's not the filter bubble
it's a future bubble
because it's the way that well that's
that's a very optimistic wonderful way
to put it i
i like that i like that term but like i
have i'm from missouri
okay my family lives in missouri they
once one's a teacher and the husband
works at a bar their kids go to school
and
the exciting [__] that they do is play
softball on saturdays
do you ever ask yourself the ideas that
i'm
coming up with or that i'm predicting
the future they're really only impacting
this
small small small tip of the iceberg of
people
how are they going to impact the random
person in nebraska or missouri
let alone you know someone in kenya or
you know what i mean do you ask yourself
this when you're thinking about what the
world's gonna look like i absolutely do
so here i'm gonna put on my pragmatic
executive whatever hat right
which is you know you have to focus at
the beginning
right and um
the way i look at it is the v1 goal
is to build a community at least with
1729 then i'll talk about the v2
is to build a community of technological
progressives who are
like i mean sort of like yc's founders
but not just
tech founders um you know people who are
media
media founders they're influencers
they're writers
they're activists for technological
progress like
isabella bemke she's like a pro nuclear
activist
or folks who are you know um for
faster approvals of drugs and devices
right
and i want to build consensus among
that group that technology is good and
that we can work together across
borders to help people achieve a better
future
not a pollyanna you know kind of oh
everything's going to be great
but certainly what i think of as the
bright sun to where the west is today
which is black mirror
you know and um i think
that uh you know that
it's sort of like at you know in terms
of your efforts how can they scale
right so my initial focus is definitely
let's call them founders but not just
company founders or broader class of
founders including media founders
protocol founders community founders
influencers etc and getting you know
some agreement among this group along
the set of ideas
and then recognizing that i personally
cannot solve all the problems of the
world
and um figuring out how we can build for
lack better term
positive sum user interfaces for those
folks
who may not be as interested in the
world of ideas and the stuff above right
how do we build uh not just positive
sound but aligning
user interfaces okay and a user
interface i use in the broadest sense
you know
um where like
you know the how your house works how
your car works how your street works how
your
community works um how can we actually
build uh things where folks are actually
aligned you know where
um the the founder or the ceo
gains or loses just as the average
citizen does
right where there it's sort of like um
and if you see the uh
the guy from chad who who just died on
the battlefield
no no so basically i think it's like the
prime minister of chad
died on the battlefield right and there
are all these memes you know why
because like of course he's a chad he
died in conflict with his soldiers right
imagine like some western leader doing
that they don't have skin in the game
right and it was it was like a joke and
it was sarcastic but it also had like a
really penetrating
aspect of truth right which is a degree
of disalignment of
western leaders and you know their their
uh their citizens right um because it
used to be that a huge
man you know like a aspect of being a
king
or being a leader was you were willing
to go into battle right
even in like world war one there was
this concept of like you know the the
nobility the aristocracy was supposed to
actually go into battle right of course
battle look we don't want to have wars
right wars are not good but the concept
of alignment
i think is a very fundamental one and in
the
communities and in the in the structures
i want to build in the future i think
that alignment has to be quantifiable
now we're actually seeing this in crypto
because um
i do think that you know one thing
people don't get is that crypto is not
just
you know the next wall street it's also
the next silicon valley because
decentralized social networks and so on
are built there
but even less obviously it's the next
yale law
and columbia school of journalism and
kennedy school of government you know
why
because yale law gets replaced with
smart contracts columbia school of
journalism with crypto oracles and
decentralized truth
and kennedy school of government because
the next heads of state are heads of
networks
okay so let's talk and look what i mean
by that is you know there's that saying
it's apocryphal but like you know give
me control over a nation's monetary
policy and i care not who makes its laws
right
it's apocryphal i'm not sure exactly who
said you've heard around
and uh so the people who who have
founded and run these gigantic crypto
networks that are sometimes in the
multiple
billions or trillions of dollars are
essentially
like you know basically they're like the
you know a fed chair
right at least of a state if not the
country
and they've gotten there by um
founding something not by winning this
whole popularity process where
as a gerontocrat at 70 they paid all
their dues and now they
finally actually can actually put their
theories into practice when they're 70
something you know
but instead as actually a founder who is
aligned with
all of their people and have all opted
in to be part of the same kind of thing
right so the short answer to your
question is
quantifiable alignment is i think the
ethical way
for those leaders to help
you know essentially the the population
that's not as interested in ideas you
know
uh let me pause there
i think sean had something yeah i
actually wanted to transition to a topic
that
i think is a little bit controversial
uh but also exciting and that's uh the
controversial part is that you know
um i'm gonna talk about crypto social
networks so
um we've talked about big cloud on here
and we got a lot of flack
we talked about it because i said wow i
think i think sean i gave us flack
yeah we gave each other flag i was
really excited and you were like dude
you're
pumping this thing i'm like no i'm not
trying to pump this thing i'm trying to
explain that
um i'm seeing some very interesting
novel
things here and uh and that's exciting
to me like i'm a product person you see
tons of products you see tons of apps
you see tons of announcements
and um you don't always see anything you
know it's sometimes
years go by between seeing something
really really interesting and the really
interesting thing about big cloud that
we talked about was number one um the
growth hack
how do you get valuable people onto a
new network um
well they loaded up a bunch of people's
accounts with a bunch of money and they
gave you know they used
economic incentive to bring high status
individuals to a new network so that was
interesting
the second interesting thing was that um
you could
you know sort of this robin hood meets
twitter you can buy somebody's coin and
in doing so
if i identify biology as an interesting
person in 2014
as some people did um i get to benefit
from the rise so a curator
would get rewards alongside a creator so
somebody who's an early
you can invest in somebody whose
popularity and reputation is going to
rise
i thought that was interesting the third
part uh
and so you know there's some interesting
parts but the there's also a bunch of
controversy
and i think that the place i want to
start is
i think that these decentralized social
networks of which big cloud is one
are very interesting because they are
like um
they took facebook's most valuable thing
right like the facebook database the
social graph
that facebook would uh you know defend
with its life
uh and they basically put it out there
you know as the
that is the product here's the social
graph with economics built in
and now any social network can be built
on top of this
uh and i wanted to hear what you see in
these social crypto social networks
because
um i think you will probably when you
look at your north star you also don't
see like 30 years from now it's you know
mark zuckerberg owning the four
most powerful social platforms and uh
we're all users and consumers and have
no economic participation i don't think
you would be excited about that version
of the future so
tell us what version of the future you
see with crypto social networks and then
try to maybe i guess talk about what
you're seeing out there today
great so i've been writing about this
stuff for a long time
um and it just disclosure by the way i
am an investor in big cloud like a small
early investor
um i wasn't involved with the project
or anything but i um i understand
why you know there's some agitation
around it and
um but i also think it's actually a good
idea
overall and i think it's uh and let me
give a few different thoughts okay
um so first
is that um
a very important concept is that crypto
is in a sense the sequel to open source
because it's not just open source it's
open state and open execution
okay so let's say it's not just that you
have the source code
you also have the database and you can
track every single
op code when it's executing okay and one
of the consequences
is you know with twitter or facebook
they have the twitter facebook api
and they can shut it off one way right
and they have you know
meerkat or um gosh teespring
zynga so many companies that built on
top of these apis have had their access
throttled or limited or their business
model destroyed overnight
because there's some change in that
one-sided you know relationship right
um and
the the thing about that is uh that's
because
if those companies had let the api be
completely open
twitter's was for a while then somebody
could clone the entire twitter
functionality
and sell ads against and then twitter
would be reduced to essentially an api
provider
and they couldn't monetize that
successfully enough to prevent that from
happening
right so i think you know tweetdeck and
so we're essentially cloning the entire
interface earlier i don't remember
exactly the details but i think that was
it
so fundamentally the issue was that the
the business model for creating an api
and a protocol that was totally open
that had state
was not feasible then okay what i mean
by state by the way just for your
audience which is maybe less technical
that's like database state that stored
state that is
um information that's not transient okay
like
uh you know i do a phone call with you
that's transient i mean maybe it's
stored on some nsa server somewhere but
we don't have a copy of it typically
right um whereas facebook has state
there's a huge amount of data they've
got
your photo and your messages and all
that type of stuff right
the crucial thing that crypto enables
the reason it's not just disrupting wall
street but disrupting silicon valley
is that as i said it's open state and
open execution so we're moving into the
third model
of uh internet technologies you know web
3. how much of your day is spent
doing some of this like crazy thinking
and
do building and working on a lot of the
stuff i mean are you um
do you grind real hard on all this stuff
or
um what do you spend your day doing
that's a good question
um i mean dave varies
because this is all heavy heavy stuff
yeah everything we've discussed is like
pretty heavy
no and you're what it's you're just
rattling this off like as if you just
like
you've like you've like already said
what you're you've already
you've thought through and you're like
well why am i wrong and then you've
already thought through it again
anyway like what's your what's your how
much time are you
uh energy are you devoting to this
throughout your day and
or like you just go for walks and shoot
the [__] like what do you what do you do
you know what i have to spend energy on
i have to spend like uh
i have to spend energy on small things
like remembering calendar appointments
and stuff like that
that is actually what is very mentally
taxing for me
um it's sort of like uh you know how
a sports car is not meant to drive on
like normal highways or you you can do
it but you just have to like kind of
watch out whatever right
um what i find hard is stuff that other
people
find easy at times like just oh
remembering that that meeting is in 15
minutes or something like that you know
because i get it getting grossed on what
i'm doing
you know um and and so what i've just
built technological workarounds to help
with that um
and so i guess the answer to your
question is
this is just how i recreate whatever
i just i just i can't stop
it you know i just go as like i walk
around and think oh that that'd be cool
this would be cool
and just tap it into my you know tweets
or my notes i'm not i'm not like
i'm not trying to humble brag or
something you're asking what my process
is
um i think part of it is i do yeah just
say the truth i don't care if you're
bragging
i'm just saying like um in terms of how
to replicate i guess what one thing i do
do is something
you know maybe similar like feynman had
this concept that i think about a lot
which is
um i have a bunch of active problems at
any one time
like how decentralized social networks
how to build alternatives to media
corporations
how to establish decentralized truth you
know these are sort of like active how
to
not miss my dentist appointment exactly
that's right right
so um the um
those those are like active problems and
um then i against them i match solutions
you know so those um
you know i've gotten you know for
example you read something you're like
okay this maps to that
right um and you know this maps to that
because
this was a problem that you had two
years ago and now you see some concept
and it lights up that this
hammer could fit this nail right so
that's that's kind of what i
try to do i don't know if that makes any
sense you also kind of help popularize
the idea maze
concept right was that you who uh kind
of coined the id amaze content
i coined the term and it was funny
because you never know what's going to
resonate with people
you know dixon actually go ahead
i was gonna say that not only resonated
with me it made me feel
much less stupid as a founder as i was
like
wandering around so okay the idea may is
i'll paraphrase kind of just
my understanding of it which was there's
this like movie
you know this this the steven spielberg
version of startups is
founder wakes up aha eureka i know
you know this is the future i'm a
visionary goes and builds the thing it's
a straight line
and yes there's adversity along the way
but the idea like
i i solve the problem and then i just do
the thing
and then like you know reality or at
least what my reality was more like was
i'm interested in like solving this
problem for people or
i'm interested in this like kind of new
space and it's all kind of foggy
and then i think i always think i'm in
the eureka moment and i'm like
yes and i sprint and then i hit a dead
end and i'm like oh [__] this is not
how things actually work this was this
product this uh
distribution strategy is not quite right
okay let me backtrack three steps and
then let me go down this other fork in
the road that we didn't take last time
and i get a bit further and i hit
another dead end and like you're
wandering around a maze and eventually
you sort of come out the other side and
that that is actually quite a normal
process for
thinking through it as an entrepreneur
trying to try to bring something to life
and make something successful that was
my interpretation and it made me
feel a lot better about hitting those
dead ends because it didn't mean
you're stupid and not cut from the same
cloth it's this is the process
or this is one version of the process at
least that is a common set of problems
so
you know carry on go back to the go back
go back a few steps and then figure out
a new way
so did i did i butcher it or is that no
that's quite good
in fact you know now like eight years
later or what have you on it
um i'll give a few other thoughts one is
it's actually
similar to like mining for gold right
you know like house
i don't know if you see that quote that
circulated um about san francisco during
the gold rush era and how similar it was
to
startup era right like yeah you know
everybody had crazy plans and there was
unlimited amounts of financing for any
kind of gold mining operation
like that culture interestingly has
seemingly a through line for 100
something years
right it really sounded like it was
describing star culture where they're
mining for gold
and their theories about this river or
this mountain or whatever is the best
way to get it
and uh you know of course tech culture
is not just
like the gold aspects the technology
aspect but that aspect is similar
and so the idea maze is like okay which
thing is going to lead to the pot of
gold it's sort of like that you know
you're
sort of like a physical gold mine so
that's one interesting thing the second
bit
is that the maze is time varying so
what's a bad idea today could be a good
idea in the future or vice versa
for example uh pandora you know
pre-iphone was only an
okay idea and post iphone it finally
became like a billion dollar company i'm
not sure how it's doing now but it did
like iphone was a lift that it needed
for ubiquitous audio everywhere right um
another is often that very small seeming
permutations can
radically change the outcomes of
companies like i remember
you make you guys remember this in the
early days of twitter and facebook i
remember people saying
why would anybody use twitter it's just
the status update function of facebook
right yeah yeah yeah okay that was a
common knock on it
but the fact that twitter was default
public number one
and asymmetric number two meant that it
just became a completely different
experience than sort of the
private set of warrens that facebook is
right fundamentally the fact that
for the most part anybody can link to
any other tweet means it's a connected
graph it's just one graph
right whereas facebook is something
where i probably can't view that
facebook post so i don't share it with
people
so it's a fundamentally private
experience so it's actually in a sense
less viral now of course i think
you know facebook it's a more successful
company and
i think it gets way more crap than
twitter even though facebook is
twitter's probably worse for the world
in some ways it's better for the world
in some ways and worse for the world in
some ways it's just this
gigantic amplifier but positive and
negative all the good stuff comes out of
twitter and all the bad stuff it's just
it's actually polygram at a good comment
on this where it's like the terms are so
large that you can't even initially sum
them to see
like whether it's positive or negative
some overall right
um oh where was i say i lost my trade of
thought uh
give me we're talking about the id maze
and you're yeah that's right okay so
come back
so now one thing i will say that i've
grown to appreciate more
is
the the specific idea makes you decide
to run really does matter
and can be like a thousand x multiplier
on the result
right so you know look genomics was
if i could show you all the good
arguments as to why genomics would be a
huge deal in the 2000s
or 2010s and i could show you the curve
of declining sequencing costs and so on
but um basically that generation of
companies was
i shouldn't say capped but it's
somewhere between like a few hundred mil
to a bill or something there wasn't a
hundred billion dollar company that to
my knowledge came out of that
um and it was sort of like that was like
the
zipcar era and then there's gonna be an
uber era coming up right
and it's really hard to know whether
you're in the zip car or the uber era of
something you know
um and often there's iterations on a
theme and it just breaks through like
and sometimes things seem tired and old
like sub stack two or three years ago
may have seemed like uh all right
whatever just another blog who cares
but adding those two features of a
monetizability
and b newsletter so that you've got um
you know because of blog by default i
mean it's not
i think maybe you can with blogspot do
emailing and so on but it wasn't like
set up for that wasn't
smack in the face for both user and
writer those two aspects really changed
things and um you know have made subzec
a breakout where
that was not obvious two years ago or
three years ago right ben ben thompson
of strategy
which subject was inspired by had been
kind of just rattling off in his own
thing for a long time
building his own thing when nobody cared
and and then it actually worked right
part of this is also the decline of the
existing media environment that's what i
mean by like
you know the iphone came and pandora
went from a bad idea to a great idea
the decline of the existing east coast
media corporations has led to this
exodus
where this thing that was okay here
became an amazing idea because there's
certainly a need for it right that
all these nails came up right um
i think insofar as i'd give advice for
people who are thinking about picking
the idea you
you really want to ask yourself if this
is a chance of being an apocalypse shift
like
search or social or you know
mobile or or crypto now right uh
or something like that and it doesn't
have to be by the way
and that apocal shift by the way might
be five or ten years out from when you
even start the thing
you know some companies just go like
vertical relatively late in life
um but you ideally want to be
part of you won't have a thesis on why
some huge trend will occur
let me give you another example of this
by the way teleport which we set up in
um 2014. just uh i was just going to ask
you all about teleport
um i'm i'm trying to find the old
website was it dot was it just dot
com.org
why so
can you well the way that i understand
it is teleport was going to
crawl aggregate tons and tons of data
and tell you the best place to live yeah
because here's the thought
basically um
an extremely valuable search engine
maybe the most valuable search engine
is the one that tells you the
economically best place to live
because well it wasn't just economically
was it wasn't it just
it wasn't just economically but the
concept was that every other quality of
life metric that you had
to a first approximation we could
have you implicitly put a dollar value
on it
like how much more is it worth and and i
say implicitly
it'd be like okay this place is
you know three thousand dollars a month
in expense but this place is thirty five
hundred dollars however
it is warmer and so out of millions of
like choices like that you could sort of
back out the function of how much more
people value that extra degree of warmth
do you see what i'm saying right yep
yeah it still gets a fair bit of traffic
it looks like still people are still
going to this people using
[Music]
teleport i think is uh
i think we're completely right about
everything that people wanted i mean it
was fine it was a fine result like stan
and you know silver did fine you know
um and um why did you say sten and
why did you say they did fine well i say
they just
because they basically just define their
careers as a function of that
like um
those are the two co-founders with me so
stan and silver early skype employees
and
they've done they're doing great um and
uh
it was it was a fine outcome um but it
was also a little too early
you know and basically it's something
where
if teleport and um nomad list is the
other one by the way which is also quite
good by this guy which i love
i think that guy's awesome yeah yeah
he's he's uh
he's actually uh levels i o on twitter
uh and
yeah he's good because the only thing
that i think he's probably a little
too aggro on is like he's so he's
anti-investor and there's bad investors
there's also good investors
so that's something whatever you know
probably it might just be a twitter
twitter thing where if i got the second
bit or third bit of information he might
agree there's some value added people or
whatever
um but uh
the thing is that nomad list and
teleport i think essentially
had worked out the theory of this almost
a decade ago
you know that digital nomadism would be
valuable that people would want to
relocate because
um the reason i just say economics
weather is just you can put a number on
it right
and so that's something you can plug
into an algorithm and um
do you know what constrained
optimization is yes okay
all right so basically i mean is that
basically where you put you
very purposely constrained something oh
to be happy yeah yeah so in
in math you know there's something
constrained optimization is like
um i want to
um optimize my
uh you know like uh the amount of time
that i spend delivering packages subject
to the following constraints
a you know the uh car can only hold so
many pounds it can only
take so many packages at a time b um
you know it has to have this many stops
you know between refueling and so on and
so forth you have these constraints on
the optimization
okay um and what you try to do is you
take all those constraints
you try to express the entire thing
often in terms of minimizing or
maximizing
a single number that's called the
objective okay
and so no matter how complicated all the
things you are that are putting in the
first order second or third order things
um you're just minimizing one objective
so you think about the best place in the
world to live
you actually want to think okay how do i
like imagine
like uh green hills and red valleys like
green is good and red is bad like a heat
map
you know of good places and bad places
to live right and so it's a scalar
and so you can basically to first order
think of that as the net economic
benefit or loss i would have in
relocating from here to here
okay and so you take all of these layers
on the world
so first is cost of living second is how
much you'd make in that geography
right third is like you know is there
bars or nightlife if interest in that
fourth if you're older you know do they
have schools
do they have airports uh is there is it
green
what is the you know what's the rule set
like you know like uh
is x band or is y legal you know and so
and so forth
all of those you layer on top of each
other and you have actually a very
complicated
mathematical optimization problem right
which actually varies for somebody
at uh different times their life you
know the best place to live when you're
you know a 20-something college student
you want the bars and nightlife but
if you've got children you're probably
thinking about schools and just a
different set of considerations so
the greens and reds change you know um
we could quantify all of that right said
here is that it would be the search
engine
that would give you the maximum value
right
it would basically be something where by
changing your xy location
you might gain you know like fifty
thousand dollars
hedonically of which maybe twenty or 30
thousand dollars is economic and the
other
remainder is in quality of life let me
pause here could this company
co could this had worked um i mean i
was okay it wasn't a failure but it was
it's something like
zipcard uber if it had been an operation
uh
or if it had been like the main thing in
20 if we had started in 2019 and 2020
it'd be in the pandemic right
like um or you know arguably it's still
early i think it's still early because
uh
post-vaccine is when travel truly opens
up
you know and when everybody's fully
vaccinated so it's like mobile phone
installs it'll take a while
and hopefully there won't be you know
variants that present immune escape that
can that can actually get out of um
of the vaccine we'll see what happens or
the vaccines
but modulo that i think you will have a
ton more you already are seeing folks
going to miami and so on
like the the the map is becoming mobile
even as states are doing lockdowns you
have the other thing which is the
centralized lockdowns and the
decentralized
you know global migrants right so i
think tools for international relocation
are still early
if anybody wants to build like teleport
2.0 or nomad list 2.0 dm me
you know with the demo and i'll
definitely take a look so i think we're
still very early in that space
when when by the way right now um i i
have no idea where you are right now but
uh if you were doing making your own
personal
teleport list which cities most interest
you for
for living in long term have you heard
the term entrepot
maybe i mispronounced it e-n-t-r-e-p-o-t
um
so that's basically like a uh like a
commercial
center um you know typically a port or
or you know something like that
historically but
i think those are waxing in importance
okay so uh you know dubai
right monaco um singapore
actually miami which is pretty
interesting americans think of miami
as a party destination you know with sun
and beaches and so on and so forth
but antonio garcia martinez actually he
was
he turned me on to this i had not
actually been aware of this till his
essay i think in 2019 he's from miami
what he said is really interesting which
is miami is like the singapore of latin
america
which is to say that if you've got like
a you know mexican national
and a guy from paraguay and they want to
do a deal they'll do it in miami
because everybody knows it they all
respect it it's like a decentralized
you know demilitarized zone it's got
good banking rule of law because based
in the us at least relatively to
south america latin america more stable
currency relative to there
we'll see what happens in the future and
um
so it's a spot where people from the
latin and south american
you know diasporas they all have like
uh communities in miami right so it's
actually this international business
capital
that many americans are just not aware
of they just think there's a beach place
right
so it's actually a great spot for all
this tech
vc the fusion there is going to be
fascinating i think we're going to see
way more stuff done
not just south of the border but in
south america there's a lot of talent
down there of course
but now you just kind of have eyes on it
looking at a new light
and you know there's actually another
aspect non-obvious aspect which covet is
going to
increase investment you know what that
is
no the world has gone remote and
what that means is that longitude rather
than latitude is now the organizing
principle
basically what you care about is not
where somebody is if they're not in the
office
then the next question is what time zone
are they in right yeah
right and so you know this is something
there's a website things called time.is
i posted on this tweeted on this right
but what that means
is longitudinal arbitrage
okay that's interesting airbnb founders
or whatever they did this where they
went and worked in argentina because
it's sort of like
low cost of living at the time and then
also like sort of time zone wise you're
still lined up with the united states so
it's like
you can go i'm sure but yeah i don't
know if it was
was it coinbase was that what it was
armstrong did that i'm not sure if the
airbnb founders did too but
yeah brian armstrong of coinbase was in
argentina at a time
before columbus uh are you so
interesting are you
uh are you aware of what it's like to
talk to you
um no
i would say it is like um you know some
kind of
it's like this it's like an amusement
park ride um but it's the one
it's the one that's like you know the
bungee and it's the bungee
only two people can go on at any one
time and they basically they swing
and they're like super high up and then
they hit the ground and then they like
spring forward and go the other way and
they just keep going back and forth
and yeah that's what it feels like
because you're like it's like
exhilarating there's really interesting
topics
but you get so high up you know as the
as the
sparring partner you're like i'm out of
my dick and then you come back to
root and you say something that's like
oh that speaks to my life experience
and then it goes back okay well we're
too far in the future again
i can't i can't i can't see anymore and
then we're back to earth and so
i meant that as a i mean that as a
compliment but i also i was just curious
like
you know that uh when you're you you're
com your brain is completely normal to
you you live there all the time
uh you know and and for me and sam i
don't know i can't speak for saying but
i know for me
um i love uh talking to you i love
listening to you and you know any
conversation we've had whether through
dms phone call or whatever has always
been great
but i'm you're the only person i i talk
to frequently
that that makes me feel out of out of my
depth where i'm like you know what i
i kind of wish you had a better sparring
partner in here who knew what the hell
you're talking about and can actually
like push this even further
whereas what i'm trying to do almost is
bring it back down to like
and who do you feel that way yeah that's
what i was
who do you feel that way with oh
i mean like feinman ramanujan
like you know there's like geniuses that
walk the earth right or have walked
there like
i talked to a guy who's good friends
with um what's his name um
what's the vc ball uh andreessen
mark andreessen and they're like um
they're like when i talk to him i just i
can't keep
up do you feel that is this is what i
think i think what you're saying is sort
of like
is that a good sparring partner for you
who do you have good thoughts bars with
um and those might be other people that
people should go follow or listen to
because
if they like what they're getting from
you maybe that's another person i think
i think you know mark and i have kept up
a high bandwidth conversation for almost
a decade now mark and ben
um for sure uh neville robbie kant
um you know who's a very good friend of
mine uh
and um
armstrong fred ursum um these are really
smart guys who
like basically folks who i get a bounce
from
every single day you know and i think
you know i just played tennis with them
um
but it's also something where they're
not exactly playing the same sport you
know
like racquetball versus tennis so as i
learned something you know
um i don't know i mean
like i i
i i try to learn i mean actually sergey
brin had a good one-liner on this a long
long time ago which is
you know every interview he did he
wanted that person to teach them
something
right which did a few things first is
men even if the interviewer didn't hire
them
he gained something out of it right but
second is it's also sort of
got their um their teaching abilities
out on
on you know and that's actually useful
because you often have to do something
within a company then teach other people
what you did
right coming back up you know think of
you know when i do these podcasts i'm
they're so they're totally off the cuff
right so it's totally
you know just freestyle and uh so in the
edited version i think i would try to
map the points such that it's
bullet bullet bullet specific specific
specific specific general
specific specific general like more
disciplined in terms of
how i accumulate to a thesis right and i
think you know
i think maybe two a few good examples of
that if you look at the
biology.com posts on india
you know like uh why india should buy
bitcoin
how india legalizes crypto um ad crypto
india stack i think that's sort of more
the sort of
workmanlike you know set up
this this and this premise conclusion
you know over and over again i think
it's reasonably well written
okay at least it's it's comprehensible
but that's like the
install software in the most eff install
intellectual software the most
efficacious way but they do
you know what i mean by that install
intellectual software yeah exactly
yeah that makes sense to me when you say
it yes yeah you get it right like what
go ahead sam you're gonna say so so you
you've been blogging on there for a
while
i've i've been reading it uh you've been
doing
you did teleport like in what 2014 which
was
uh right or ish um which was about like
kind of making it making predictions
you've been all about predictions i mean
it seems like that's been part of your
your personality for a very long time
what predictions did you make
10 years ago about the year 2020
that were wildly wrong and that and
you would have bet a lot of money that
they were going to be correct like
you're really bought in on them and
they've proven to be wrong that's a good
question
um i mean there's lots of things so many
things have gotten wrong
i mean one thing that's kind of
interesting you know i only really
became a public figure in
2013. you know public figure i don't
know if you i didn't call myself that
now
but like i only actually wrote publicly
in 2013
before that i was sort of you know
cloistered in academia or in genomics
it's like it's like an enterprise
founder
who just doesn't ever take the mic or
whatever you know so to speak right
um and i had plenty that i was thinking
i was writing about but
um i wasn't even speaking publicly on it
and
um i think that
one big thing i got wrong was um
i i was just never like i'm the
personality for cryptocurrency i'm not
really the personality for early social
networks which were
all about exhibitionism and remember
zombies that game
you know like people wasting time online
all that type of stuff that's like
totally not me and uh so i i actually
you know there's people who dismiss
crypto as oh
it's you know it costs too much
or it's it's just a scam you know they
just didn't get it you know for a long
time and then there was eventually a
light bulb moment
um social networks like
i i i sort of got the appeal of it being
like a facebook online remember the
concept of a facebook
i'm gonna forget you guys are old enough
actually sam you're actually relatively
younger
but something's almost impossible to
google this is funny
google the stanford facebook haha you
know it's like three proper nouns
but um back in the late 90s and early
2000s
a facebook was a noun which was it was
something that was given out to
freshmen um when you came no i yeah
you're aware that yeah
well yeah and i mean i had my brothers
you're probably 10 years older than me
yeah i have brothers at all yeah i know
you're talking about okay well so
that's something which um was a physical
facebook and i understood the appeal of
like putting that online
but i i i only actually understood
like the power of social networks uh
when there was a friend of mine
who was live tweeting a genomics
conference
okay i was like oh
that saved me a flight nobody would have
written up
the material as well as this scientist
would have
because they would have just you know
messed up the terminology
or made it confusing they certainly
wouldn't have gone into as much depth
and i was just able to like just slurp
in and download
like five hours of presentations without
a plane flight
you know um at my laptop in 10 minutes
and get the important bits and i was
like
that i really like a lot okay i actually
understand the value of that
i did not understand the value of
tweeting your breakfast right that
seemed to me the stupidest most
exhibitionist
like waste of time thing in the world so
what did you predict that it just
i'm like it might sound like arrested
you might say small
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i underestimated
when social networks were basically
voyeurism and exhibitionism
and time wasting and zombies and so on
i i i did not
really think through their social impact
right
it was only after and the thing is that
the reason that genomics thing really
piqued my
interest is because i realized that was
something that
would only be feasible when the thing
has achieved such massive scale
that even this very niche niche niche
niche application
was feasible you know it's like like you
have gigantic scale thing
google and then you can google like i
don't know belgian cooking recipes or
something like that right french cooking
recipes maybe that's not that niche but
what i'm saying right
um so social networks i
only after i uh i understood that
that they weren't just time wasters or
distractions
that you could actually learn things
with them so i i very much
underestimated social
um and um
i think that i probably overestimated
genomics
you know uh what i what i got wrong with
that
was i saw i think all the technology and
the computer sciences all of that you
know there's a curve by the way that
your
your audience can google which is like
cost of sequencing a human genome like
nhgri
national human genome research institute
and that like was just
dropping through a cliff in in the late
2000s and it was clear that this looked
like a moore's law like thing and
moore's law catalyzed quite a lot of
stuff so get into that
what i didn't understand as an academic
and i only understood as an entrepreneur
is what the fda really was
you know i didn't understand that like
basically the fda is like the primary
blocker
of like medical innovation not just in
the us but in the world people are now
by the way catching up to this
you know because of the disaster of the
fda holding back
authorization on covet testing them
doing things like holding back the
johnson johnson vaccine because like one
out of a million people literally are
getting blood clots
you know this type of stuff people are
understanding that their degree of risk
aversion
is not actually optimal there's both
type one
and type two errors both false positives
and false negatives
and uh if you are rejecting good drugs
or
good vaccines or good tests you are
potentially doing as much or even more
damage than bad one than approving bad
ones and
people are only focused on the pr
downside of approving a bad thing
and not on the unseen of not approving a
good thing right
you you basically wanted to be the ron
swanson of the fda
you know you wanted to you wanted to get
elected of the territory well no
no actually that's why i didn't take the
position and in fact it was a surprise
to me
uh because i the paradox of that is
obvious right
like um google didn't reform microsoft
by becoming
you know bill gates google reformed it
by building a parallel system
and then once it had made billions of
dollars and after 10 years
of microsoft throwing everything in the
book then they replaced their leader
bomber with satya and then they reformed
and embraced open source right
so i don't believe that one can abolish
the fda
any more than one can abolish the fed
but i do think you can exit the fda like
we exited the fed
and you exit the fed with bitcoin it
required like basically
you know this uh this this development
of both technical and cultural and
economic breakthroughs to build a
parallel financial system
which started off as just a crazy
person's
you know vision of the future right um
but some people
got the potential very early on like
california was speculating that could be
like one to ten million dollars per coin
very very very early on i think like on
the first threads like if bitcoin took
over right
i wonder if he was satoshi's friend or a
colleague or something like that that
was just sort of
lending his name to this anonymous
project to give people
you know a second look at it right hey
actually this this pseudonymous guy is
actually maybe better than he seems it's
possible right
point is though that parallel system was
built outside the existing system
and was completely ethical because
everybody who is engaged in it have
opted into it
right it's not forced on anybody and all
the bugs every hack
every loss of funds every drop or surge
in the price
uh every technical difficulty every ux
difficulty
all that was opted into completely
ethical
opt-in experiment right at the broad
scale which is the opposite by the way
of monetary policies that are forced on
you top down from above
you had no ability to take the
non-inflated usd
after 2008 right but if you disagree
enough with the cryptocurrencies
monetary policy you can fork the entire
economy
go your own way right that minority
report does exist
it may not be successful but then you
know that's in the execution
so one thing i think about a great deal
is
what is to um our existing institutions
what crypto was to finance right so you
can see
already a crypto law with smart
contracts for big chunks of law
you can start to see crypto media in the
sense of decentralized cryptographic
truth and the crypto oracles things i
was talking about where
the foundational assertions are not
human beings dumping their chests and
saying science
capital s you know or with quotations
right but rather
cryptographic facts by the way can i can
i dive into
that for a second on quote-unquote
science versus science this is a very
important issue
okay let's do it so you've seen all
these people
who are like masks don't work because of
science
masks work because of science right and
essentially
what they actually are saying is some
authority figure
has told me that this is true and
therefore it is true it's not actually
science is not about peer review it's
about independent replication
that's a fundamental difference right
peer review is at best a proxy for
independent replication there's a
premise that that guy who reviewed it as
a peer
actually went and grabbed the bubbling
beakers and did the experiment
themselves
that's less and less the case today most
of the time it is or maybe it's less
than this case forever most time it's
like a few emailed comments and like
make a new figure
okay right so the the actual
you know like independent replication is
download the code and run it on my
machine
okay now there's only one thing
which has now first let me back every
second science is actually
the ostensible basis of our civilization
you know
why it's no longer religion right you
don't cite
god or the ten commandments as why have
this law
it is science says that there's a
certain amount of emissions so therefore
this policy is there right
science says there's certain amount of
viral particles so therefore we wear
masks versus not and so on and so forth
right
so upstream of everything is a
scientific premise
which is then coming in uh often from
peer review
as opposed to independent replication
which is subject to institutional
capture which is what's happened and you
start to get
scientists saying more and more
ludicrous things
that are you know like all the public
health people just completely
own themselves during the pandemic in
many different respects like
they admitted that saying that masks
don't work was a noble lie
right um which which was it wasn't even
that noble it was just stupid it was
obvious at the time
you know um and you can't do that too
many times and there's many more
examples of that's a particularly
egregious one
you can't do that too many times before
people just don't trust it right so
what's the alternative what's up
because you know the answer isn't in my
view to go to astrology or wu
or stuff like that what do we have not
science there's only one thing that's
more prestigious than science
what is that
more prestigious than science it's not
usually thought of as
being an opposition what is it
math okay what do i mean by that
when i say math greater than science
okay
it's like kind of a one-liner it's like
a funny headline or whatever but let me
expand what i mean by
that um every scientific paper
is based on the collection of
data and the generation of like figures
and tables and so on right
um there's a concept called the open
access movement which is about putting
research online and taking it out from
behind these publisher payballs
there's also a concept called
reproducible research which says that
that scientific paper should be fully
reproducible
from the underlying data and code like
you should be able to hit enter and just
like you can template a web page with
parameters from a database
you can template a scientific paper with
uh calculated parameters from that data
set
okay there's there's uh sites like
distill.pub
or if you look at what openai does like
a lot of their
uh papers are basically like interactive
websites which operate in this fashion
where the underlying data set is like
templating the page okay what's the
point
the point is that um
it is when i talk about science as being
independent replication yes it is
impractical
for everybody around the world to have
their own inclined planes and cloud
chambers
to try and replicate all these
experiments we don't have those but what
does everybody around the world have
computers yes that's right they have
computers
they have phones they can't necessarily
do science at home but they can do
math on the computer
so the more of that independent
replication process that you can turn
into
math the more that people
who do not trust a central authority can
check
the the claims okay now
we've already seen a huge victory of
this right which is
uh you know scientific economics has
been defeated by
mathematical economics that say all
these nobel laureates
winners of the nobel prize in economic
sciences all went and denounced bitcoin
in different ways it can't work it won't
work it shouldn't work it should be
banned and mathematical economics
defeated like these quote scientists and
i put them as quote-unquote scientists
because they're not
you know one of the big things by the
way is it's like um
scott alexander calls it the skin suit
you know like
science is like newton and maxwell and
the crucial thing is like maxwell's
equations
have trillions of independent
replications every single time you pick
up a cell phone
you're doing an independent replication
of you know the equations for the e and
the b field for the electrical and
magnetic field right
and and a thousand other things you you
there's there's equations for
quantum mechanics that you're
effectively replicating independently
confirming because the engineering
wouldn't work if the science system
right
so those things have trillions of
independent replications
and it's a total category error to
compare them to a study that came out
last week
that has basically zero replications
right calling them both science means
you're taking things the only similarity
is like they're coming out of
universities but the axis on which to
compare
is the number of independent
replications not the number of citations
number of independent replications and
what's awesome about this is this is
actually where crypto is
if you think about what does it mean to
have a transaction confirmed on chain
i don't know if you've ever seen
blockchain.com have you ever sent any
cryptocurrency and refreshed
blockchain sean maybe i've sent it a
whole bunch of times but i never
sort of tracked and traced the the
transaction before you know sort of
the log i never looked at the log of the
transaction look at the log
and for example yesterday when i went
and said i was donating you know
money for indian coveted relief i was
able to post the link
on chain so people could see the funds
flowing
and see that i donated exactly as much
as i said to the address that i said was
going to donate at the time that i said
i was going to do it right
um and and the critical thing there is
there's a thing that says number of
independent confirmations
how many different miners right have
confirmed
that a did b at z
time okay independent confirmations are
very similar to independent replications
that's cool they're actually doing
calculations all of them are doing
mathematical calculations to confirm
that this fact this assertion actually
happened that you had the digital
signature that owned this cryptocurrency
zone that seems like a very limited
scope but as i said we can expand that
to property we can spend it to lots of
other things right
and crypto oracles what's the point the
point is
uh if you take the concepts of open
access the concepts of
uh reproductive research the concept of
independent replication
and its proximity to the multiple
confirmations
of on-chain data right uh you can think
about something where
oh actually all these people have
computers so if the code and the data
set for every paper were actually on
chain
not only could i independently replicate
at least
their post upload conclusions right they
may have still falsified the data by the
way that's still possible okay
but post upload every calculation
they're making
i can check moreover if all of that is
on chain
it's an open state database going back
to our previous point right
so every paper can be compared against
every other paper we can have common
formats rather than every
paper using a different format right we
can
import a library from a previous paper
just so you can import a library
from github because again it's all open
state right
and so now you actually start to make
science
far more checkable and cumulative
because
it is only the uploading process
which now is in doubt everything that's
on chain
at least given this data i can check
their calculations i can check their
figures i can check their tables
i can also check their citations because
i go back a few hops
and they're importing this paper
importing that paper and i can actually
see that their
uh premises i can check their premises
as well i can map the trail of citations
all the way back right
all of which is actually quite difficult
to do today you know only google can
build like google scholar
because they have access to all these
journals it's all behind paywalls right
some of it has been broken out there
with like pubmed central and so on but a
lot of it is still behind payballs
or it's like a thousand different
formats right and this is similar to how
you know banking before crypto was a
thousand different formats it's like
you know this wire transfer and this
address and so on and crypto uniforms it
or like
it unifies it in a uniform address right
a dress format that's universal and
global
point being this is actually a way that
uh you can decentralize science
by actually realizing that math is
actually more powerful than simple
assertion and using math
and all the computers that we have do
independent replications
of every post upload claim all right i
know i just threw a ton at you there
um you threw a ton yeah
but that's like a recipe for like what
crypto science or decentralized science
might look like
and just like a quick question you're
you were a partner at a16z is that what
you were doing
um a general partner for a while and
then a board partner was part-time um
versus you know operating a company you
um
you're just you're just a weirdo and i
love it you're just so
interesting you're just so odd and like
who like you're just sitting here
talking about
math and science and we did crypto we
did starting traditional
tech companies we did uh where to live
battle the ball i don't think about
where to live
yeah yeah like you you you're eclectic
um well we can go deep on a specific
topic if you want actually i'd love you
to teach me something about newsletters
because
um you built a large one um so maybe you
know
like i can ask you you know what would
you like given that i've got
you know a newsletter that pays you
maybe you can teach me something about
that and i can learn
i could teach you yeah i mean i could
teach you everything about newsletters i
don't know if i could do it today it's
1am right
um but i bro i could
i mean i i can't imagine there's that
many people in the whole world that know
more about me than newsletters you know
like
what you are to crypto i am newsletters
it's unfortunate
it's unfortunate that crypto is far more
lucrative but uh
oh you're okay you're quite well and and
you know the thing is
as you know if you one of the funny
things about this whole
space this just this tech thing is
if you just stay in the game long enough
and you take enough swings
ones that you just don't expect will
just connect much harder i mean like
you know there's investments that i've
made which i spent
five minutes on that have returned more
than like five months of work of course
you're still taking capital risk
you know it's not like a free money or
anything like that right but
um no i mean you're like you're a very
successful entrepreneur
and you're in the game and so just put
some of that newsletter money into
crypto or other things
i'm happy or media foundation i did i
and i actually i
there's like a famous story that i
retail over and over and over again but
the short of it is i was
friends friendly with ross albright um
oh and and uh when he was arrested i
didn't know that that's who he was
and i was sitting next to my co-worker
and i go billy
my guy ross just got arrested you heard
of this thing called silk road
and billy it's not same as billy draper
oh and he was like
and he was like yeah my dad said that
bitcoin is like gonna be the coolest
thing ever and i said
sounds good to me i'll go and buy it so
i bought it
i don't know what it is but your dad is
smart
i'll do what he says good so that that's
like myself
i mean poor ross i didn't actually know
his name was albright i thought it was
all bricked
uh but uh all bro actually i don't know
how it's pronounced but uh yeah poor
ross
definitely uh yeah we weren't like crazy
close friends we we've hung a couple
times and i lived in glen park
where he lived and i was at like in
front of the library the day he got
arrested
on that topic it is surprising to me
given all the malfeasance that came out
afterwards that that
there hasn't been a retrial you know
literally like agents falsifying
information and so on
and that's just what's come out to the
public like who the heck knows
if you know it was all like i i haven't
gotten into details on this but i do
understand that like
the supposed you know hits that he
ordered were all faked and it was just
all entrapment or something like that
and well the
they were faked whether that was
entrapment or he meant to
murder someone that's up for debate yeah
i i i said i haven't gotten into the
guts of it i like that you uh
i like that you try to like and
everybody knows the right thing to do
and then most of us don't
always do the right thing whether it's
food or it's consuming information
it's like ah maybe this is [__] but
it's entertaining so i'm gonna i'm gonna
do it anyway i'm gonna
read it watch it anyways uh and it's
sort of like you know warren buffett
he's brilliant in one thing and then he
you know drinks like whatever six jokes
a day and eats mcdonald's every day you
know he's mcdonald's for breakfast every
day
he's living until the 90s so his
constitution manages to keep up with
somehow or
yeah yeah i think he's he's pretty
stressed for you which i think is it
works for him uh do you have something
like that where you're like
yeah i'm super smart but this is the
dumb thing i do and i know it's dumb but
i do it anyways
watches the challenge on mtv yeah me and
sam
we both watch shitty reality tv and
we're like yeah we know there's better
things to do but we do this anyways
big kardashian fan a a big kardashian
pin um
you see basically asking like what you
know creature comfort type stuff
um i mean you know like you know
like things you know us normal humans do
no i mean
i i like i'm on i'm on twitter or
whatever you know and that's like
certainly a huge waste of my time
um it's both good and bad it's one of
those things where you know
every time you you you get out they pull
you back in you know like godfather
right
um i
uh i once watched a movie yeah
i watched tons of movies tons and tons
of movies basically like
less so recently though it's interesting
i
you know actually one of the things i
found you know just on the like the
biology
like preferences becoming the future
kind of thing right let me give you some
this is not the answer to your question
uh but let me rip on this and then come
back to your question okay
um
there's for example in 2005 uh when
google maps was out but before the
iphone came out
when i wanted directions to something
what i'd do is i would
use google maps on my laptop i would
screenshot it i'd charge up the laptop
i'd also print out the screenshots in
the event that there was a power outage
and then keep the laptop and the
screenshots on the passenger side
of the car as i drove okay and that's
like
that's why i knew the iphone with maps
would be a success because i had this
crude jury rigged version of it in that
interim period when google maps existed
but the iphone didn't okay
it's like a small example right um
certain things that i've
been noticing actually as i just talked
to you i was like you know i really
haven't
watched that many movies recently and
why is that it's like well so many of
them are woke that i kind of just roll
my eyes and i know exactly what it's
going to be like hollywood's gone so
woke
and uh and that's just like being
preached to right even if
you might agree or disagree with some of
the like you know principles there it's
just like
all right again blah blah blah right and
uh
it's very predictable it means the
characters are hacknide it means the
messaging is
is is just so on the nose you know that
there isn't any of the humor and so on
that used to characterize it there's so
many areas that are off bounds that
like it's just also edited and i just
found the quality of hollywood has been
dropping off a lot
another thing i've realized is i don't
hire actually from
stanford or harvard or mit or whatever
anymore you know where i hire from
twitter me too okay
because basically uh it's first it's
international
second is you can kind of tell that
these folks can write
you can see what they're you can see
what they're about you can see what
they're about it's actually
it's like a v1 of this concept of like
um
it's a com you might think about how you
didn't get like too much signal on them
from their diploma
right yeah you get way more signal from
their writing and interests and so on on
twitter not just their skills but their
values and character
right and you know there's like super
smart guys
in you know nigeria you know smart women
in like the middle east and so on
who you could they shine through i'm
like okay that person
right and you've now got like an index
on on the world that you didn't have
before
rather than just buying this this degree
right
in fact actually i'm not i don't quite
say they're
guilty till proven innocent but unlike
you know five or ten years ago a lot of
these
graduates of woke schools i mean i think
of them as like
uh you know like religious education now
because that's what they're prioritizing
i don't know if you see this thing like
they're abolishing accelerated math in
virginia and so on and so forth right
and uh so so it's actually something
where these folks are coming out of
higher ed with
a religious education that basically
means that they are
not necessarily all that technically
good anymore and a set of priorities and
entitlements
that is very much often adverse to what
is needed to build a business
you know and so i i think there's been
like the college flipping for me
at least in terms of hiring from these
places and said you know you want to
hire
the the guy from the midwest or the
middle east who just has
like you know just a different set of
values and it's just more hungry
you know um what's up yeah exactly right
exactly
what's your hollywood what's your
hollywood replacement in that same way
so that's your hiring replacement you
said
your hollywood consumption goes down
what'd you replace it with
um old books
uh math textbooks um
i thought something what like normal
people do or whatever you know that
that's like a
fridge uh so you know before i started
my first company i was actually about as
jacked as as possible to be with my
south asian physionomy
um and uh so it like lifted and ran
all the time i worked out all the time
and it was very difficult to
do that while operating startup because
you know your
first priority is like
there's always the temptation to make
that short-term sacrifice
of stay up late or skip the workout to
take the sales call
and frankly your employees like uh
you're at least what i told myself the
time the employees
you know you give your responsibility to
them which um
your small health or your hour of sleep
isn't as important as
their you know because you have a
fiduciary responsibility to them you
know you brought them on you have to put
them jobs move across the country
oh i didn't do that deal because i went
for a run oh okay
well you know and it took me a while to
realize that actually
that was a false economy and um
that you know like spending down your
physical fitness or your health
is actually something that will also
impoverish them
in the medium to long run because you
won't be
you know you can only tap into that uh
in your youth you can push harder of
course right but as you
ouch um as you get older um
the uh you just don't have the energy to
do that in quite the same way right you
can't tolerate asthma are you yo
are you are you fit now i'm fitter than
i was
um i basically one of the things that
actually i did at 70 29
is uh you know we've been doing this
thing proof of workout
right where you can submit like proof of
work haha get a proof of work out right
where you submit um a proof of work out
we give you
10 bucks in btc if it's one of the top
100 of that day
okay and it's kind of cool and it's got
extremely good response
and basically what i realized that for
the next thing that i did
i actually had to make that part of like
the job
and the business such that everybody
expected me
uh just like i expected all our
employees to go and exercise
and because it was actually something
that advanced the company as a whole
and i just had you know whatever just i
can only do one thing at a time
so i needed to actually make that a
front page priority in sort of the same
way that people um
have learned that spaghetti code is a
short-term optimization
and actually you're taking on technical
debt you're taking on physical debt
if you are not like working out and
eating right each day you know
so i wanted to kind of put that in the
top my consciousness for the next thing
um and i actually think that that daily
fitness
eating properly etc is on a straight
line with
transhumanism and with reversing aging
and so on and so forth and whether we'll
be successful in that i don't know
but at least i want to at least set that
direction vector
i like it i think we lost sam to a
bathroom break because we
we've broke the the my first million
record of longest podcast so we should
we should wrap it up um where where can
people find you so i know twitter is
where i
kind of get the most uh so shout out
kind of where people can get more where
you go yeah go to 1729.com
um that's the free newsletter newsletter
that pays you in fact
where it's got these regular bitcoin
bounties for tasks and tutorials
and um you know i kind of spoke about
what our long-term goal is for
what we're doing there short term it's
extremely easy to understand which is
read a post do a task earn some crypto
and then you know like for example we
had yesterday uh
is um you know learning about how to
register a domain name that was very
valuable in the early 90s
well learning how to register a crypto
domain name is probably going to be very
valuable and we basically have a
tutorial on that and if you
uh go and do it and you tweet about your
experience then we'll give you 250 if
you write a good
set of tweets right like educational
informative subtweets right right
so that's like a cool i think a way to
incentivize you to learn something that
you should already learn and
so we're giving out like five thousand
dollars in ethereum for that right so
sponsor uh could other people sponsor
like could we oh yeah put up five grand
for
something absolutely so we have 1729.com
princess
create okay and one thing that i want to
have eventually is something
you know just like companies have
twitter accounts have them have 70 train
accounts where
every task that they can outsource to
the public at large they do
and maybe they pay them in their
corporate cryptocurrency
yeah i love that i love this sort of
mini x prize i we've been talking about
this on the pod for a while as like
i love that the x prize was this kind of
big pinata that got a bunch of people to
innovate
and step up and actually more investment
than the prize
yeah that happened because of it uh and
i wondered i know i i i've now
experienced a big company we got
acquired and i'm like oh i understand
why it's so hard for bigger companies to
innovate
i wish we were just putting more of
things on our company's roadmap just out
there and say hey if anyone can whoever
builds the best version of x
we will like sort of state up front what
we will acquire it for what we will pay
for that bounty to be complete
that's one of the sort of startup ideas
i'm most passionate about absolutely so
if you're interested in trying out some
experiments on this
like one big thing is you know i think
you're mentioning like startup ideas
that you had
so one thing i want to do is do prizes
for startup editors you know
25k for the best one in 30 days and
you know we have the right to put in a
safe or something like that you know
like
um but you know we can we can
we could figure out all those things but
if you if you just want to try something
go to 1729.com from
create and just submit a task and its
instructions are there
and if it's good we may even fund it
okay so
that's to say like the process of
creating a task meaning drafting the
copy
and the process of sponsoring a task are
actually separable things
so you could have a lot of people create
unfunded tasks and just like a vc goes
and invests in a startup
it's like a a sponsor invests in a task
and then boom
makes it go mainstream right so that
itself is like an interesting concept
where you know you don't just have uh
like um let's say hubspot having a feed
of tasks
it also has a queue where people can
propose things that would be interesting
for hubspot to try on its audience
you know that's sick man we're all right
so thank you for everything
yeah thanks for uh thanks for coming on
you know it's great to have a smart guy
come and chat with a couple of
bullshitters like us
so uh we we enjoyed the conversation
thank you speak for yourself
you guys are too self-deprecating you've
done a great job you know
your show is great and uh your your feed
is often insightful
and uh you know uh you know mutual
admiration so great job
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back